Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 42, Fortran. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everyone. So we got some interesting listener feedback uh we got a lot
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 42 期，Fortran。Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好。我们收到了一些有趣的听众反馈，呃，我们收到了很多
of interesting listener feedback uh one of them listener feedback is interesting that's true just put it out there we got we love you guys feedback of which all was interesting and uh one in particular was a strong verse weak typing so somebody corrected me and said that uh python javascript are strongly typed languages and i remember like kind of having this debate with somebody at the time but it didn't really get we didn't have smartphones and so it didn't get resolved um so i went and looked into this and it's actually really interesting this one's like as as engineers and scientists like our field is kind of very sort of pedantic and deterministic and sort of explained very well that's kind of part of our nature um but this is one of those things that's completely up to interpretation so so are you saying you're wrong or not because i don't have to print another attraction so actually nobody's right so this is so there's a kind of right i know there's a gradient on one
有趣的听众反馈，呃，其中一条听众反馈很有意思，这是真的，我就直说了，我们很喜欢你们的反馈，所有的反馈都很有趣，呃，其中一条特别提到了强类型与弱类型，所以有人纠正我说，呃，Python 和 JavaScript 是强类型语言，我记得当时我和某人有过类似的争论，但并没有真正……我们当时没有智能手机，所以问题没有解决，呃，所以我去研究了一下，这其实真的很有趣，作为工程师和科学家，我们的领域非常迂腐和确定，而且解释得非常好，这算是我们天性的一部分，但这完全是见仁见智的问题，所以你是说你错了还是没错？因为我不想再印一份勘误表了，其实没人是对的，所以这是一种……我知道这中间有一个渐变过程，在一
side of the gradient is the most weakly typed languages like um like ruby or r or you know like languages like that where there's no type system and there's no type errors so for example like in r you can do like patrick plus one and i think in r it type casts to spring to string so if you do like patrick plus one you'll get patrick one um and so that is like and also r doesn't have any you know any type safety or type checking or you know types You know as you're programming or anything like that so R is considered like very weakly typed right and it supports bare words things like that You can make Ruby similar like you can make some changes to Ruby, and Ruby will support bare words.
侧是弱类型程度最高的语言，比如 Ruby 或 R，或者你知道的这类语言，它们没有类型系统，也没有类型错误，所以例如在 R 中，你可以执行“patrick”加 1，我想在 R 中它会进行类型转换，转成字符串，所以如果你执行“patrick”加 1，你会得到“patrick1”，所以这就是……而且 R 也没有任何类型安全或类型检查，或者说你在编程时没有任何类型之类的东西，所以 R 被认为是非常弱类型的，对吧？它支持裸词（bare words）之类的东西，你可以让 Ruby 也类似，你可以对 Ruby 做一些修改，Ruby 就会支持裸词。
Bare words just means that you can say, like, Jason, go to the mall, and it will just interpret that as a string. It's kind of weird. At some point, your code can be a string, and it's kind of goofy. Anyways, so that's very weakly typed. So then strongly typed is, say,ava where you know everything is a type the type is defined um you know explicitly and at compile time you know by you and you have to adhere to that type you can't say you know person a equals like new restaurant or something you know like except for some extenuating circumstances um yeah you think about that talk to except for some extenuating
裸词只是意味着你可以说，比如，“Jason，去商场”，它就会直接将其解释为一个字符串。这有点奇怪。在某种程度上，你的代码可以是一个字符串，这有点滑稽。总之，这就是非常弱类型的。那么强类型就是，比如说 Java，你知道所有东西都是一种类型，类型是明确定义的，呃，你知道是在编译时由你定义的，你必须遵守该类型，你不能说，你知道，“人 a 等于 new 餐厅”之类的，你知道，除非有一些特殊情况，呃，是的，你想想那个……除了有一些特殊
circumstances you uh um yeah you can't do that it won't let you right so those are the two ends of the spectrum right so wait you put java on the other end that's what you said yeah i would have gone with like haskell or something or like the type type is actually used to great strength but okay it's okay go ahead that's fair i guess uh like something with a more uh in your face type system yeah yeah i mean the type so haskell definitely makes better use of the type system but i don't know if it's stricter or not okay I don't know the exact axis this is being drawn on
情况，呃，嗯，是的，你不能那样做，它不会让你这样做，对吧？所以这就是光谱的两端，对吧？等等，你把 Java 放在了另一端，你是这么说的，是的，我本来会选 Haskell 之类的，或者说类型被真正发挥了巨大作用的语言，但好吧，没关系，继续吧，这很公平，我想，呃，像那种类型系统更“咄咄逼人”的语言，是的，是的，我的意思是，类型……所以 Haskell 确实更好地利用了类型系统，但我不知道它是否更严格，好吧，我不知道这是在什么坐标轴上画出来的。
it's probably the same level as Java so Java is very strict like you can think of C++ as being kind of in the middle somewhere because it can be as strict as Java but you can also just cast anything to void I guess in Java you could have everything as an object.
它可能和 Java 是同一个水平，所以 Java 非常严格，你可以认为 C++ 在中间某个位置，因为它既可以像 Java 一样严格，但你也可以把任何东西强制转换为 void，我想在 Java 中你可以把所有东西都当作对象。
It's like all of your classes just had objects. And then it would kind of... So one part of this is it really doesn't depend too much on the language, but how the language is most often used. Because you can make Java more weakly typed
就像你所有的类都只有对象一样。然后它就会……所以这其中的一部分是，它其实并不太依赖于语言，而是依赖于语言最常被使用的方式。因为你可以让 Java 变得更弱类型
if you wanted to, but nobody actually programs that way. So the other part of this is, I sort of always said it's weakly typed if there weren't any types known at compile time. So in other words, like Python, you could say x equals three, then the very next line could say x equals Patrick,
如果你想的话，但没人会那样编程。所以这其中的另一部分是，我一直说如果编译时没有任何已知类型，那就是弱类型。所以换句话说，比如 Python，你可以说 x 等于 3，然后紧接着下一行可以说 x 等于 Patrick，
and that's fine. Like x can be whatever you want it to be. And so because of that, I would say Python, JavaScript, these languages are weakly typed. But these languages are more strongly typed than, say, R, right? Because in Python, you can't say Patrick plus 1. You get a type error. So it really just depends on sort of where you draw the line in
这没问题。x 可以是你想要的任何东西。正因为如此，我会说 Python、JavaScript 这些语言是弱类型的。但这些语言比 R 更强类型，对吧？因为在 Python 中，你不能说 Patrick 加 1。你会得到一个类型错误。所以这真的取决于你在哪里划定界限，
the sand like there's this gradient and if you draw the line at you know uh be able to support bare words and automatically type casting everything so that there's no errors then you're going to look at everything else is strongly typed and so we drew our line where we drew it um but even like professors things like that there's no no one has gone out and said okay here's here's here's what it is and so it's totally up to interpretation that was a weakly typed argument all right well anyway while jason was uh trying to assuage his problem of feeling like he got it wrong, I'm just happy it wasn't me who got it wrong. Please, no one write in and tell me the things I got wrong. I know it's everything.
就像存在这个渐变过程一样，如果你把界限划在“能够支持裸词并自动进行类型转换，从而没有任何错误”上，那么你就会认为其他所有语言都是强类型的，所以我们划定了我们的界限，呃，但即使是教授之类的人，也没有人站出来说，好吧，这就是它的定义，所以这完全取决于解释，那是一个弱类型的论点，好吧，无论如何，当 Jason 在试图缓解他觉得自己弄错了的问题时，我只是很高兴弄错的不是我。拜托，没人要写信告诉我我弄错了什么。我知道我什么都弄错了。
So I posted a link here, and you can just search W-A-T-W-A-T. Programming talk is what I searched to find it. And there's a lecture someone gave or a presentation at a conference where they go through various languages. And I think this made the rounds several times through the internet, so you've probably already seen it. Yeah, this is so good.
所以我在这里贴了一个链接，你可以直接搜索 W-A-T-W-A-T。我搜索了“编程讲座”才找到它。有人在会议上做了一个讲座或演示，他们浏览了各种语言。我想这在互联网上流传了好几次，所以你可能已经看过了。是的，这太棒了。
But this is a couple years old, where the guy is giving kind of a slick, prepared presentation about various languages and kind of using and abusing them. And he talks about bare words in there, like getting JavaScript to give you the batman theme song by causing things to be not a number when they don't seem like they should return not a number yeah um anyway so i guess javascript doesn't have bare words i guess bare words is in ruby that's right yeah and even then you have to do something special to you know enable that that bug
但这已经是几年前的事了，那个人正在做一个相当圆滑、准备充分的关于各种语言的演示，并以某种方式使用和滥用它们。他在里面谈到了裸词，比如让 JavaScript 通过在不应该返回 NaN 的地方导致某些东西变成 NaN 来为你播放蝙蝠侠主题曲，是的，呃，总之，我想 JavaScript 没有裸词，我想裸词是在 Ruby 里，没错，是的，即便如此，你也必须做一些特别的事情来启用那个 Bug。
oh oh i see oh maybe that wait you mean that internet talk i watched wasn't completely up front well actually they are if you see like the part where he's like you can do this and the supports bare words he actually like hacks together some function which like does some ridiculousness yeah okay well i've always felt like if if if a language is weakly typed like python or javascript then it's um it's only good for kind of like so there's a bunch of different you should say weaker typed yeah it's true weaker type so i my my my like litmus test is this if the if the program is meant to run for an hour or longer then you use a strongly typed language other people have said things like oh if it has more than 100 lines of code you know don't use python and so there's just various different metrics but at a high level like the weaker the typing is,
哦，我明白了，哦，也许那个……等等，你是说我看的那个互联网讲座并不完全坦诚？好吧，其实他们是坦诚的，如果你看到他像“你可以这样做，它支持裸词”的那部分，他实际上是拼凑了一些函数，做了一些荒谬的事情，是的，好吧，我一直觉得如果一门语言是弱类型的，比如 Python 或 JavaScript，那么它……它只适合那种……所以有很多不同的……你应该说“更弱类型”，是的，没错，更弱类型，所以我的试金石是这样的：如果程序打算运行一小时或更长时间，那么你就使用强类型语言，其他人说过类似“哦，如果代码超过 100 行，你知道，就不要用 Python”之类的话，所以有各种不同的衡量标准，但从高层来看，类型越弱，
the better you have to check, you know, either if it's weakly typed, either your program needs to run fast, in which case, you know, if the program takes a second to run, then it really doesn't matter whether you get a compiler error or runtime error, right? Or you have to do a very good job checking all of the code paths so if it's if it's intended the program's intended to run for like days and days then hopefully like there isn't some syntax error or some just goofy type error you know in some if statement that only runs once a day yes that is something that annoys me about python i had written a tool that had worked flawlessly my team was using it no complaints and it turned out there was this bug where if you
你就越需要检查，你知道，如果是弱类型，要么你的程序需要运行得很快，在这种情况下，你知道，如果程序运行只需要一秒钟，那么你得到的是编译器错误还是运行时错误真的没关系，对吧？或者你必须非常出色地检查所有的代码路径，所以如果程序打算运行几天几夜，那么希望不会出现什么语法错误或什么愚蠢的类型错误，你知道，在某个每天只运行一次的 if 语句中，是的，这确实是 Python 让我感到烦恼的地方，我写过一个工具，它运行得非常完美，我的团队一直在使用它，没有任何抱怨，结果发现有一个 Bug，如果
uh it was properly looking for the error to occur it was reading um data in and if it saw like a improperly formatted something it was supposed to print out like what why it was improperly formatted except that the thing i was printing out was of a different type than i expected it like think uh i was i was assuming it would be a list and instead it was just uh or an array and instead it was just a string so i was trying to you know kind of undo the wrapping of the list to print it cleanly and no one hit this bug for you know however long then finally like we had some bad data come across and you know it crashed python instead of giving the nice printout of like hey i saw you did
呃，它在正确地寻找错误发生，它在读取数据，如果它看到格式不正确的东西，它应该打印出为什么它格式不正确，除了我打印出来的东西是我预期的不同类型，比如，我想，我假设它是一个列表，结果它只是……或者一个数组，结果它只是一个字符串，所以我试图，你知道，撤销列表的包装来整洁地打印它，没有人遇到这个 Bug，你知道，过了多久，最后，我们有一些坏数据进来，你知道，它让 Python 崩溃了，而不是给出像“嘿，我看到你做了
something wrong and i'm gonna close gracefully it just you know uh stack unwound oh really you didn't get just like a python error you got a python error but like the whole oh okay here trace back the trace back for Python. Right. That had been there for who knows how long. Yep. And a compiler, I guess, you know, in theory, if they were stronger typed than it is, I would have been able to detect that the thing I was passing around wasn't of the type it
什么错，我要优雅地关闭”这样的漂亮打印输出，它只是，你知道，呃，堆栈解开了，哦，真的吗？你没有得到一个 Python 错误？你得到了一个 Python 错误，但就像整个……哦，好吧，这里是回溯，Python 的回溯。没错。那东西已经在那里待了谁知道多久了。是的。而编译器，我想，你知道，理论上，如果它们比现在更强类型，我就能检测到我传递的东西不再是它曾经的类型，而我已经改变了它。是的。没错。是的。我有一堆 JavaScript 代码，我有那个潮汐，你知道，公司维基就在上面，而且我有……我实际上写了一个 Meme 生成器，所以我工作时我们只是开些有趣的玩笑并互相发送，我在想，哇，你真的想被解雇吗？我知道，我其实在想……
once had been and that I had since changed. Yep. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. I have a bunch of javascript code i have that title wave you know the company wiki is on that and i have the um i actually wrote a meme gen meme generator so i work we just make like funny jokes and send them to each other and i'm thinking wow you really want to get fired i know i'm actually thinking about uh
呃，所以有一门语言叫 TypeScript。我们之前谈过 TypeScript。但 TypeScript 的酷之处在于你可以从 JavaScript 开始，然后慢慢添加类型注解。然后最终，一切都是静态类型的。如果你没有类型，TypeScript 会有点抱怨，但不会太大声。所以你可以慢慢迁移。我想这样做，因为这就是你谈到的。偶尔，有人会弄崩溃
like so there's this language called TypeScript. We've talked about TypeScript before. But the cool thing about TypeScript is you can just start with JavaScript and then slowly add type annotations. And then eventually, like, everything is statically typed. And if you don't have a type, TypeScript will kind of, like, complain but not too loudly. So you can sort of migrate slowly. And I want to do that because this is what you talked about. Occasionally, someone crashes
整个公司的维基，这是因为代码的某些区域我没有很好地测试，或者只是一些如果用类型安全就能捕获的愚蠢错误。这不是强类型或弱类型。是……或者更弱类型，是的，没错，是的，是的，在你称某物为强类型之前，你必须设定你的参考点，所以最强类型的是如果你只允许一种类型，比如像那样的整个程序，它全是音乐之类的。只有一个操作，对吧？那叫什么？
the wiki for the whole company and it's because it's some area of the code that I hadn't really tested well or just some goof that would have been caught with type safety. It's not strong or weak typed. It's or weaker typed yeah that's right yeah yeah before you say something is strongly typed you have to put your reference point so what would be the most strongly typed would be like if you only allowed one type um like a whole program like that one where it's all uh it's all music or something. There's only one operation, right? What is that called?
就像完全由 NOR 门构建的计算机。哦，是的。总之，没关系。但我不知道只有一种类型是否会让……我的意思是，我想一门没有多态性的语言会更强类型，因为你不能真正做任何愚蠢的事情。比如 Java 有
It's like the computer built only out of NOR gates. Oh, yeah. Anyways, it doesn't matter. But I don't know if having just one type makes the... I mean, I guess a language that had no polymorphism would be more strongly typed because you couldn't really do anything goofy. Like Java has
对象，但除非在非常特殊的情况下，否则没人真正使用它。所以我认为 Java 是非常强类型的。我猜如果你只有一种整数类型，比如只有无符号 32 位整数。
object, but nobody actually uses it unless it's very specific circumstances. So I would say Java is very strongly typed. I'm guessing if you had only one integral type, like only unsigned 32-bit integers.
你在说像 Fortran，像早期版本的 Fortran。所以，是的。嘘，嘘。伏笔，伏笔。那叫 Jason 没听出来。剧透警告。哦，天哪。
You're talking about like Fortran, like the early version of Fortran. So, yeah. Shh, shh. Foreshadowing, foreshadowing. That's called Jason not picking up on that. Spoiler alert. Oh, my God.
那很有趣。新闻。哦，天哪。那很有趣。新闻！天哪。好吧，所以第一篇新闻文章是这个非常酷的东西。它叫 Disk。所以有 Redis，Redis 非常酷。
That's funny. To the news. Oh, god. That's funny. To the news! Oh man. Okay, so first news article is this pretty cool thing. It's called Disc. So there's Redis, and Redis is pretty cool.
所以其实，让我们退得更远一点。有 Memcached。Memcached 是由 LiveJournal 的 CEO 或首席工程师编写的，LiveJournal 是 15 年前流行的一个社交网络。Memcache 所做的是简单的键值查找。如果你有访问非常频繁的键，
So actually, let's step back even further. There's Memcached. Memcached was written by the I guess CEO or head engineer of LiveJournal, which was a social network that was popular 15 years ago. And what Memcache does is just simple key value lookup. And if you have keys that are accessed very frequently,
Memcache 做的正是它所说的。它将它们缓存在内存中，然后就不必去磁盘了，如果你有一些使用频率不高的键值对，那么在 Memcached 中就会失效，然后你就会去你的数据库或其他什么地方，所以这个想法是，你知道，你的标志，你的公司标志，每个人每次加载页面时都会看到，访问非常频繁。所以 Memcached 会在某种意义上免费地获取像你公司标志这样的东西并将它们缓存在 RAM 中。
Memcache does exactly what it says. It caches them in memory and then doesn't have to go to disk and if you have some key value pairs that are not used very frequently then in memcached falls through and then you would then go to your database or what have you and so the idea is you know your logo your company logo which everyone sees every time they load a page, is accessed very frequently. So Memcached would just, for free in a sense, take things like your company logo and cache them in RAM.
所以你不会有……它减少了你的数据库开销。所以 Redis 基本上是 Memcached 加 1。所以它的接口更容易。它更干净。它可以做一些很酷的持久化。所以如果你的机器挂了，它可以存储到磁盘。所以当机器重新启动时，它不必像即时重建缓存那样。它有很多像这样很酷的东西，而且它更现代。所以现在如果你看看消息队列空间，这是你有不同的机器想要互相传递消息的地方。你知道同样的事情，有 RabbitMQ，有 Kafka，有 Camel，有这些中的一堆，
So you wouldn't have, it reduces your database overhead. So Redis is basically Memcached plus one. So it's just the interface is much easier. It's much cleaner. It can do like some cool persistence. So if your machine dies, it can store the disk. So when the machine comes back up, it doesn't have to like rebuild the cache on the fly. It has a bunch of cool things like that and it's just much more modern. So now if you look at the message queue space, this is where you have different machines they want to pass messages to each other. You know the same kind of thing where there's RabbitMQ, there's Kafka, there's Camel, there's a bunch of these,
但它们都有些陈旧过时，或者它们很慢。所以终于有人浏览并构建了 Disk，这是一个完全在内存中的消息传递子系统。看起来很酷。我一定会研究一下。所以我可以在我做了一些研究后在未来告诉你们更多，但呃，它看起来……它看起来会
but all of them are kind of old and antiquated or they're slow. So finally someone kind of went through and built Disk, which is a completely in-memory message passing subsystem. It looks pretty cool. I'm gonna definitely look into it. And so I can tell you guys more in the future after i've done some study on it but um it looks like it looks like it'd be
很有用，我的意思是很多人现在使用 Redis 进行消息传递，但它并不是为此设计的，所以他们有点……你必须做很多技巧才能让它工作，消息传递需要很多调整，比如所有不同的选项，比如如果接收方主机挂了，消息是否可重新传递，或者那种可配置性，但这个有一个巨大的警告，它仍然处于 Alpha 状态，不要在生产环境中使用，对吧？是的，呃，所以我从来不知道当东西说那个时，它是否真的意味着它，因为很多软件都这么说，而且就像每个人都使用下一个版本的 Alpha 版本，因为它好得多，而且已经发布了一年，而不是像“哦，不，我真的是上周末写的，它可能很糟糕，不要尝试”，是的，这就是问题所在，你知道，显然你在修复
pretty useful i mean a lot of people right now use redis for message passing but it's not really designed for that so they're kind of you have to do like a lot of trickery to make it work well message passing is needs a lot of tuning like all the different options like messages being re-deliverable if the host the recipient dies or that kind of configurability but this one has a giant warning that it's still alpha state and don't use in production right yeah uh so i never know when stuff says that if it really means it because a lot of software says that and it is like everyone uses like everyone uses the alpha version of the next release because it's so much better and it's been out for a year versus like oh no literally i wrote this last weekend and it's probably awful don't try it yeah that's the thing like you know obviously you're fixing
Bug，当你得到它们时，所以随着时间的推移，你已经，你知道，比如在版本 2 中，你修复的 Bug 比版本 1 多，这是一个保证，因为修复的 Bug 数量只是单调增加，对吧？或者至少不是在减少，呃，但正如你所说，你知道，Alpha 版本有一大堆新功能，并且大概增加了新的 Bug，所以它只是……所以 Bug 的数量可能会更高，但是的，我认为就像你说的，你必须阅读文档，试着读懂字里行间，弄清楚那个人是否真的意味着“这是 Alpha，因为我在 TechCrunch Disrupt 上拼凑了它，而且我当时喝醉了”。或者这是 Alpha，因为我还没有正式证明
bugs as you get them and so like as time goes forward you've you know like in version two you have more bugs fixed than version one that is a guarantee because the number of bugs fixed is just monotonically increasing right or at least month is not decreasing um but as you said like you know the alpha version has a whole bunch of new features and presumably adds new bugs and so it's just so the number of bugs might be higher but yeah i think like what you said you kind of have to read the documentation and just try and read between the lines and figure out if the person really means like this is alpha because i hacked it together at tech crunch disrupt andrupt. And I was drunk at the time. Or this is alpha because I haven't formally proven
所有的代码行。或者发生更多的情况是，这是一个破坏性的更改，我目前不想处理社区。所以我只想继续黑客攻击，一次性完成，撕掉创可贴，这发生了很多项目。当我发布这个时，很多人会生气。所以我必须确保我真的知道会改变什么，然后我会发布它，是的，这就是 Spark 发生的事情，很长一段时间 Spark 只是有点非常不稳定，然后有
all of the lines of code yet. Or what happens more is this is a breaking change and I just don't want to deal with the community at this time. So I want to just keep hacking away and do it all at once and rip the bandaid off, which is what happens to a lot of projects. When I push this out, a lot of people are going to be mad. So I want to make sure I really know what will change and then i'll push it out yeah that's what happened with spark like for a long time spark was just kind of very unstable and then at one
一点，在某个时候他们说，好吧，让我们只是，你知道，重构整个东西，让它变得漂亮和干净，所以呃，最近亚马逊的季度财报出来了，我们有义务给你们提供与编程无关的新闻，他们的股票飞涨，呃，除了人们只是说股票上涨是因为股票上涨之外，主要原因之一，试图把它归因于某些东西，因为股票变动总是必须有一个原因，是亚马逊第一次报告了他们来自网络服务的收入。所以亚马逊云，AWS，亚马逊网络服务，我想，AWS，他们正在销售服务器，租用服务器给其他人以便能够运行。
point at some point they said okay like let's just kind of you know refactor the whole thing and make it nice and clean so uh recently amazon's quarterly earning report came out and our obligation to give you news not related to programming uh their stock jumped through the roof um one of the main reasons other than people just saying the stock went up because the stock went up um trying to pin it on some, because stock movements always have to have a reason, was that the Amazon, for the first time, reported their revenue from their web services. So Amazon Cloud, AWS, Amazon Web Services, I guess, AWS, they are selling servers, renting servers to other people to be able to run on.
而且，你知道，它变得非常流行。每个人可能都听说过它。但在那之前，它一直只是业务的其他部分之下。但这个季度，他们终于把它拆分出来了。他们的收入为 15.7 亿美元，这很多。但以真正的亚马逊风格，他们设法赚了很多美元，但利润少得多，2.65 亿，所以 2.65 亿仍然是一大笔钱，呃，但 15.7 亿确实是一大笔钱，就像亚马逊，这是我不理解亚马逊的地方，
And, you know, it's become really popular. Everyone probably has heard about it. But before, it had always been kind of just under other parts of the business. But this quarter, they finally broke it out. And they had a revenue of $1.57 billion, which is a lot. But in true Amazon fashion, they managed to take a lot of dollars and profit much less dollars 265 million so 265 million is still a lot of money um but 1.57 billion is a really a lot of money like amazon this is the thing i don't understand about amazon
他们以非常好的供应链管理和非常低的运营成本而闻名，但他们也以消耗掉大部分收入而闻名，我不明白这怎么可能，呃，我不知道这个，是的，我的意思是这就是他们出名的原因，但部分原因是，呃，我认为他们坚信成长而不是原地踏步，所以他们可以原地踏步赚更多的钱，但他们想继续雇佣工程人才，投资仓库，缩短交付时间。我前几天在想那个。我有 Prime，我不得不开始交税。
they're known for like really good sort of supply chain management and having very low operating costs yet they're also known for blowing through most of their revenue i don't understand how that's possible um i don't know this yeah i mean this is like what they're known for but part of it is uh i think they have a strong belief in growing and not sitting still so they could sit still and make a lot more money but they want to keep hiring engineering talent, investing in warehouses, pushing delivery times down. I was thinking about that the other day. I have Prime, and I had to start paying taxes.
现在我最终，因为那个，他们受到了很多抨击，很多人离开了它。但现在我实际上在一天或周日收到很多包裹，因为他们在我的州加利福尼亚州建立了仓库，因为他们失去了税收减免之类的东西，或者那不是它的名字，是的，没错，呃，所以我觉得他们愿意积极追求昂贵的东西，为了某种程度上确保未来的总收入增长，即使这意味着他们的利润会下降一段时间，但他们觉得这就是他们不能，
And now I eventually, because of that, they took a lot of flack, a lot of people left it. But now I actually get a lot of packages on one day or on Sunday because they've put warehouses in my state california um because they lost the tax shelter thing or that's not what it's called yeah that's right um so like i think they are willing to aggressively pursue things which are expensive um for kind of securing future total income growth even if it means that their profits will be down for a while, but they feel like this is how they can't,
他们不仅仅成为另一个购买东西的廉价地方，对吧？这就是为什么他们没有被 eBay 或其他人击败，因为你仍然去亚马逊，他们仍然供应数百万种产品，在一天或两天内交付。人们真的很喜欢那样，但留住人很昂贵。人们会因为任何原因离开。所以你不能给他们哪怕一个。
they don't just become another cheap place to buy stuff, right? It's why they didn't get beat out by eBay or by someone else, because you still go to Amazon, they still supply millions of products, deliver them in a day or two. People really like that, but it's expensive to keep people. People would leave for any reason. So you can't give them even one.
是的。亚马逊也做了一堆非常酷的事情。他们有这个东西，他们拿走了某种程度上他们的分销主管，比如最常卖的商品。然后他们拿走了他们的人口，他们试图估计，比如可能性，考虑到你知道一个有一百万人的城市，其中一个人会买这些流行商品之一的可能性是多少，一旦那个足够高，他们就直接发货，所以换句话说，比如 HDMI 线，它们已经坐在离你家最近的分销中心了，因为是的，加利福尼亚的一个人想要 HDMI 线，比如加利福尼亚中部想要 HDMI 线的可能性太高了，
Yeah. Amazon also does a bunch of really cool stuff. They had this thing where they took sort of like the head of their distribution, like the most commonly sold items. And then they took their population and they tried to estimate like the likelihood given you know a city of a million people what is the likelihood that one of them will buy like one of these popular items and once that's high enough they just ship it so it's so in other words like like hdmi cables like they're already sitting in the distribution center closest to your house because yeah the likelihood of one person in
以至于他们总是可以在那里保持供应，然后实际上只需要开车 10 英里给那个人。你可以想到同样的事情，就像沃尔玛知道第一场寒冷的暴风雪袭向一个城镇，一群人会去买加热器，是的，没错，是的，就像那样，但呃，但快得多，但总之他们的 AWS，我的意思是他们继续推动并成为市场领导者，他们是最大的呃云服务提供商，优势相当大，这张图表超级有趣，就像他们实际上即使他们是最大的，他们也只有 28%，另一个很疯狂，我不知道呃什么
California wanting an HDMI cable like in Central California wanting HDMI cable is so high That they can just always keep a supply there and then literally just have to drive it like 10 miles to that person You can think about the same thing as like Walmart knowing that the first cold blizzard headed to a town a bunch of people are going to go buy heaters yeah right yep it's like that but uh but much faster but anyways their aws i mean they've continued to push and be a market leader and they are the biggest uh cloud services provider by a pretty good margin and this chart is super interesting like they actually even though they're the biggest they're only 28 the other was crazy i don't know uh what
Jason 正在看一个饼图，显示了呃云收入或云业务的百分比细分，有一个巨大的块，只是有点像其他人，但它是一个大块，所以我不知道这到底是怎么回事，这是来自《纽约时报》，他们是如何分类的，好吧，是的，它构成了云服务，是的，我的意思是他们按顺序做，那么这意味着 43% 的市场被每家公司不到 3% 的公司所消耗。这意味着至少 12 家公司都在分享 2% 或 3%。
jason's looking at a pie chart that's showing the breakdown of uh percentage of cloud revenue or cloud businesses um and there's a huge chunk which is just kind of like everybody else but it's a big chunk so i don't know exactly how this is from the New York Times how they're classifying well yeah constitutes a cloud service yes I mean they do it in order then what that means is 43% of the market is consumed by by companies who have less than 3% each. That means at least 12 companies that are all sharing 2% or 3%.
在这里，Dropbox 不在上面。但考虑到像 Salesforce 这样的其他名字，我想 Dropbox 可能在某个地方。Dropbox 在亚马逊上运行，对吧？是吗？如果你有像……但如果你有像
On here, Dropbox isn't on here. But given these other names like Salesforce, I would imagine Dropbox is probably on here somewhere. Dropbox runs on Amazon, right? Does it? If you had something like but like if you had something
那样，对吧？如果你有 Dropbox 或 Netflix，对吧？它们将是巨大的贡献者，它们恰好在亚马逊上运行，我想你是对的，但是的，这超级有趣，伙计，难以置信，我不知道，我一直认为，其实我以为亚马逊大得多，就像我以为亚马逊会像 50%，然后他们不是，要大得多，是的，但看看如果他们是 50% 那会有多少钱，那会超过 30 亿美元，是的，一个季度，哇，一个季度，哇，难以置信，而且这也是非常稳定的钱，不像你知道，你必须等待假期之类的。酷。
like that right like if you had drop box or netflix right they would be big contributors they happen to run on amazon i think you're right but yeah that's super interesting man unbelievable i had no idea that i always thought actually i thought amazon was much larger like i was expecting amazon to be like 50 percent and then they're not to be much up yeah but look how much money that would be if they were 50 percent that would be like over three billion dollars yeah a quarter wow a quarter wow unbelievable and it's very consistent money too it's not like you know you have to wait for the holiday season or something. Cool.
那太棒了。是的，所以我的下一篇文章是 JQ，这是一个命令行 JSON 解析器。所以很多人，绝对如果你在做任何网络相关的事情，即使你不是，你可能也在用 JSON 做某事。它就像 XML，但它更简洁。而且你不必匹配开始和结束标签，这总是一场噩梦。所以绝对，如果你想存储一些数据，JSON 是一个很好的选择。这是一个非常酷的命令行解析器。所以把它想象成 JSON 的 sed 工具。所以你可以说，嘿，进去并撕掉这个
That was awesome. Yeah, so my next article is JQ, which is a command line JSON parser. So a lot of people, definitely if you're doing any web stuff, but even if you're not, you're probably using JSON for something. It's like XML, but it's much more terse. And you don't have to get matching the opening and closing tags, which is always a nightmare. And so definitely, if you want to store some data, JSON is a good way to go. This is a pretty cool command line parser. So think of it as like a sed tool for JSON. So you could say, hey, go in and rip out this one
对象，搜索对象，过滤对象，之类的事情。看起来很酷。我一定会试一试。我其实今天才发现它。但他们这里有一些例子。而且我
object, search for objects, filter out objects, things like that. Looks pretty cool. I'm definitely going to give it a shot. I actually just found out about it today. But they have some examples here. And I
发现自己经常需要这样的东西，呃，在服务器端，就像只是做一些分析，比如我们使用很多 MongoDB，在 MongoDB 中，你知道一切都是呃 BSON，但它实际上是存储在二进制中的 JSON，但从你作为数据库客户端的角度来看，MongoDB 正在存储 JSON 文档。所以如果你想把它转储到磁盘然后看一看，这是一个非常酷的工具。所以是的，去看看吧。它叫 JQ。
find myself often needing stuff like this to uh on like server side like just to do some analysis like we use a lot of mongo db and in mongo db you know everything is uh a bson but it's really a json stored in binary but from your perspective as a database client mongo db is storing JSON documents. And so if you want to dump it to disk and then take a look at it, this is a pretty cool tool. So yeah, check it out. It's called JQ.
我可能做了一些可怕的事情，也可能没有。我写了一个命令行工具，它接受一个 JSON 字符串作为命令行参数。不，那很好。不，这很疯狂，是的，我的意思是，我做了它，它运行得非常好，我认为这是一个优雅的解决方案，但当我告诉人们，比如“哦，是的，这个工具”，他们说“你知道工具接受什么参数吗”，我说“它接受这个这个，然后它接受一个 JSON 字符串”，他们说“什么”，我说“好吧，所以它就像一个模板
I may or may not have done something awful. I wrote a command line tool that took a JSON string as a command line argument. No, that's good. No, it's crazy yeah i mean i did it it was it worked really well and i thought it was an elegant solution but when i told people like oh yeah this tool they're like you know what parameters does a tool take i'm like it takes this this and then it takes a json string and they're like what i was like well so it was like a templating
系统，所以你有像一个模板文件，你试图在它上面运行一些东西。JSON 字符串保存了模板中要替换的内容，但你可以命名它很多很多不同的，比如单个变量，很多东西。而且这是最快的方法，说，我想动态地提供一整套替换。而且，你永远不会手动创建字符串。就像你通常从另一个工具运行这个工具一样。没错。没错，没错。
system so you have like a template file and you're trying to run something on it. And the JSON string holds what to replace in the template, but you could name it many, many different, like the individual variables, many things. And it was kind of the fastest way to say, I want to provide a whole list of replacements dynamically. And it, you don't ever create the string by hand. Like you typically run this tool from another tool. Right. Right, right.
但是的，我有点像，人们看着我很有趣，当我像“所以是的，命令行参数之一是一个 JSON 字符串”。所以这是它的反面。解析 JSON 字符串的命令行工具。是的，我的意思是，我认为，如果它是一个简单的事情，它只是
But yeah, I was kind of like, people looked at me funny when I was like, so yeah, one of the command line arguments is a JSON string. So this is the reverse of that. The command line tool that parses the JSON string. Yeah, I mean, I think that like, if it's a simple thing where it's just,
你知道，一个对象列表，或者也许只是，我的意思是，一个数字列表，或者它只是简单的事情，它只是你知道一个对象列表，或者也许只是我的意思是，一个数字列表，或者它就像一个对象，那么就像，是的，我的意思是，为什么你要自己做那个解析，当你可以直接告诉人们时，那就是它，我本可以写像任意命令行解析一样，比如，对吧，名字冒号替换，名字冒号替换，比如，是的，巴拉巴拉，做那个，但它来自已经来自一个文件，它是……总之，有原因，但我感觉有点像可能有更好的解决方案。我只是不想等。
you know, a list of objects, or maybe just, I mean, a list of numbers, or it's just simple thing where it's just you know a list of objects or maybe just i mean a list of of numbers or it's just like one object then like yeah i mean why would you do that parsing yourself when you could just tell people that was it i could have written like arbitrary command line parsing like right like name colon replacement name colon replacement like yeah blah blah blah do that but it comes from already comes from a file that is... Anyways, there's reasons for it, but I felt kind of like there's probably a better solution. I just don't want to wait around.
是的，我的意思是，JSON，这是一个很好的主意。我的意思是，是的，根据情况，从包含 JSON 的文件中读取可能会更好。有原因我不能那样做。很公平，很公平。好吧，你拿下一个，是的，所以这个现在有点老了，但我认为它非常有趣，所以 GitHub 几周前受到了拒绝服务攻击，呃，而且事实证明，特别是网站托管
Yeah, I mean, JSON, this is a great idea for that. I mean, yeah, depending on the circumstances, it might be better to read from a file that has the JSON in it. There was reasons I couldn't do that. Fair enough, fair enough. Okay, you got the next one yep so this one is a little bit old now but i thought it's really interesting so github came under denial of service a couple weeks ago um and it was turned out that specifically a website hosting
规避中国防火墙，中国防火墙，无论它叫什么，中国防火墙，呃，阻止中国境内的人获得被审查的新闻。呃，它，呃，我猜就像它的代理。
uh circumvention for the firewall of china the great firewall of china whatever it's called the chinese firewall that, uh, prevents people inside of China from getting censored news. Um, it was, uh, I guess like a proxy for it.
呃，而且它变得相当出名，中国政府现在回想起来，似乎对它感到生气。所以他们对呃 GitHub 进行了攻击，特别是这个页面。当然，你知道，中国有像很多很多计算机。
Uh, and it was like getting pretty well known and the Chinese government now in retrospect, seems like it got mad about it. And so they made an attack against, um, GitHub specifically this page. Um, of course, you know, China has like many, many computers.
而且它看起来确实像这个不是来自一个孤立的地方，而是来自中国的所有计算机。进一步的分析显示，百度，也就是搜索引擎，中国最大的搜索引擎，是每个在百度上运行搜索的人。所以，你知道，很多很多不同的计算机。他们会注入一个广告，那个广告的一部分就是去 ping，你知道，从他们试图取下的这个网站检索数据。所以，而且它每两秒钟做一次。所以只要你在搜索结果页面上，
And it actually looked like this one was coming from not a single isolated place, but all the computers in China. And further analysis showed that Baidu, which is the search engine, biggest search engine in China, was everybody who ran a search on Baidu. So, you know, lots and lots of different computers. They would inject an ad and part of that ad would be to go ping, you know, retrieve data from this website that they were trying to take down. And so, and it would do it every two seconds. So as long as you were on the search results page,
它就会一直点击 GitHub 服务器，他们会跨越这个。百度和……之间有什么联系？哦，百度是中国的网络搜索东西，对吧？但它是一个托管在防火墙后面的网站，没人确切知道他们是怎么做的，但我猜怀疑的是，当防火墙在服务页面时，它会自动交换广告，所以百度不一定参与其中，但防火墙能够动态切换广告，哦，有趣，所以每个去百度的人都得到了这个注入的广告替换，对吧？呃，这导致了这一点，所以 GitHub 的回应，这非常好，是他们在被拉取的字符串中添加了一个 JavaScript 警报，比如“请停止这样做”或
it would keep hitting the GitHub server and they would do this across. What's the connection between baidu and oh baidu is the chinese web web search thing right but what it was is a website hosted behind the firewall and no one knows exactly how they're doing but i guess suspected was that they when the firewall was serving the page it was automatically swapping the ad so baidu wasn't like necessarily in on it but the firewall was able to switch the ads dynamically oh interesting so everyone who was going to baidu was getting this ad injected replacement right um that was causing this and so github's response which was pretty good was they in the string being pulled they added a javascript alert like please stop doing this or
类似的东西，所以如果你的计算机反复尝试这样做，它会得到一个警报，JavaScript 处理会停止，直到你清除警报，这意味着每个人的计算机只会做一次，直到他们点击确定，它会惹恼人们，比如人们会立即像“什么，这是什么”，是的，所以中国政府抨击 GitHub 很有趣，因为你不会认为 GitHub 是像，我不知道，政治活跃，但是的，他们可能只是不知道呃呃它是什么，就像他们不知道 GitHub 只是开源任何东西，他们可能认为它是特定于这个东西的，好吧，可能是中国政府要求 GitHub 取下它，而 GitHub 说不，我的意思是它可能是任何数量的事情，我不知道那里的故事，但阅读关于
something and so if your computer was repeatedly trying to do this it would get an alert and the javascript processing would stop until you cleared the alert which meant that each person's computer would only do it once until they clicked okay and it would annoy people like people would immediately be like what what is this yeah so it is interesting that the chinese government lashed out at github because you don't think of github as being like i don't know politically active but yeah they probably just didn't know uh uh what it was like they didn't know that github was just open source anything they probably thought it was specific to this thing well it may be that chinese government had asked github to take it down and github was like no and i mean it could be any number of things i i don't know the story there but it was just interesting to read about
攻击是如何进行的，找到它，弄清楚它，有点可怕，就像中国政府在攻击一个企业，比如一家公司，对吧？而不是另一个政府，这难以置信，然后你知道，美国不一定回应，比如“嘿，停止攻击 GitHub，否则我们要攻击你”，但是的，这只是奇怪，对吧？你可以呃，就像我猜，只是从数学上看着它，看起来你可以通过使用某种基于 BitTorrent 的互联网浏览器轻松突破中国防火墙，对吧？好吧，我的意思是，我认为有很多方法可以绕过它
like how the attack went down finding it figuring it out it was kind of scary that like the chinese government was attacking a corporate like a company right like not another government it's unbelievable and then you know the u.s doesn't necessarily respond like hey stop attacking github or we're going to attack you like but yeah it's just weird right you could uh like i guess so just looking at it mathematically it seems like you can trivially break through the Chinese firewall just by using some kind of BitTorrent-based internet browser, right? Well, I mean, I think there's lots of ways around it
对于知道或想要绕过它的人来说。但问题是仍然有恐吓。如果你规避这个，我们会来找你。但他们不能，对吧？我的意思是，你可以制造像相当无法追踪的，对吧，是的，但你要拿你的生命去赌吗？其实你知道，困难的部分呃，不是不是获取信息，而是然后是，是不使用它，就像换句话说，如果我使用像某种 Tor 浏览器来阅读 CNN，
for people who know or want to get around it. But the problem is there's still intimidation. If you circumvent this, we will come and find you. But they can't, right? I mean, you could make like pretty untraceable right yeah but are you gonna bet your life on it actually you know the hard part is um is not not getting the information um but then is is not using it like in other words if i if i use like some kind of tor browser to read CNN,
现在我知道了中国没人知道的事情。所以如果我开始告诉我的邻居关于这篇很酷的 CNN 文章，现在突然之间，就像那就是你会被抓住的方式，对吧？就像当你，最终你会告诉某人，比如对中国有同情心的人
now I know things that nobody else in China knows. And so if I start telling my neighbors about this cool CNN article, now all of a sudden, like that's how you're going to get caught, right? It's like when you're, eventually you're going to tell somebody who's like sympathetic to China
他们会向警察举报你，然后你就会去坐牢，就像那其实就是你会被抓住的方式，是的，我试过和人们谈论它，我总是从在中国待过、住过或在中国出生的人那里得到不同的呃回应，但你知道，我认为中国政府的一部分只是，不是试图阻止一个坚定的个人无法看到信息，而是某种程度上只是阻止它进入社会的时代精神。明白了。
and they're going to tell the police on you and then you're gonna go to jail like that's actually how you'll get caught yeah i've tried to talk to people about it and i always get different uh responses from people who have spent time in china or lived in china or born in china um but you know i think part of the chinese government is just is not trying to keep a determined individual from not being able to see the information, but to kind of just stop it from entering the zeitgeist of society. Got it.
它没有变成，就像普通人在街上听到一个词的耳语，不能直接去查一下并弄清楚。就像你必须在寻找它，去，确定你要去找到它。我曾经工作，有一次我在这个公司工作
It's not become, like the average person just hearing a whisper of a word on the street can't just go look it up and figure it out. Like you'd have to be seeking it out, going, determining that you're going to go find it. I was working, once I worked at this company
它并没有变得像普通人那样，在街上听到只言片语就随手查查就能弄明白。你得主动去寻找，去下定决心把它找出来。我曾经工作过，有一次我在一家公司工作
where they blocked a bunch of pages on the internet. So Gmail was blocked and things like that. There are more than one such companies, yes. Yeah. I wrote this fork of Google Chrome called Google Crime, C-H-R-I-M-E dot E-X-E. And it was just a fork of Chromium that would just basically bounce the data off my computer at home and let me get on Gmail. I found out like a few months ago that there are people at this company
他们封锁了互联网上的许多页面。所以 Gmail 之类的都被封了。这样的公司不止一家，是的。没错。我写了一个 Google Chrome 的分支，叫 Google Crime，C-H-R-I-M-E 点 E-X-E。它只是 Chromium 的一个分支，基本上就是把数据从我家里电脑中转一下，让我能上 Gmail。我几个月前发现，这家公司里还有人
still using it. And it's not updated. So there's a bunch of people who are still using like google crime circa you know seven years ago to get on gmail everyone has smartphones now i know right that's what i said but but they're like no well you know we want gmail on the desktop and this is the way to get it why i guess it's like you know the like stuff has come so far on mobile now like i have my phone and it gets you know automatic notifications without even using that much data it pushes them to me it just pops up a notification like i don't need it on my desktop i think it's like it's just the risk reward right like they feel like i mean the google crime stuff's already done so there's no risk and they don't feel like they're gonna get fired or anything and so it's like there's just virtually no risk and so even
在使用它。而且它没有更新。所以有一群人还在用七年前左右的 Google Crime 来上 Gmail。现在每个人都有智能手机了，我知道，我也这么说，但他们说：“不，我们想要桌面版的 Gmail，这就是获取它的方法。” 我想这就像是，移动端的技术现在已经发展得这么好了，我有手机，它能自动接收通知，甚至不需要消耗多少数据，它会把通知推送到我手机上，直接弹出来，我不需要在桌面上用它。我觉得这就像是风险与回报的问题，对吧？他们觉得 Google Crime 已经做好了，所以没有风险，他们也不觉得会被解雇什么的，所以几乎没有风险，因此即使
if the reward is just marginal like you have gmail on your desktop and your phone they just do it anyways i would say these people should find a new job but if they're just using your tool from seven years ago instead of rewriting it for themselves to get it updated fair fair point those people are probably listening um anyways all right time for a book of the show book of the show so um oh i had something i really wanted to talk about but uh anyways we can save it for next show. But actually, we'll talk about it after Book of the Show, just a very short interjection. So my Book of the Show is a theory of fun in game design, which is pretty cool. This book was loaned to me from a friend.
回报微乎其微，比如你在桌面和手机上都有 Gmail，他们还是会这么做。我会说这些人应该找份新工作，但如果他们只是在使用你七年前的工具，而不是自己重写一个来更新它，这倒也是个合理的观点。那些人可能正在听。嗯，不管怎样，现在是“本期书目”时间。本期书目……哦，我本来有件很想聊的事，但算了，我们可以留到下期节目再说。其实，我们会在“本期书目”之后聊聊它，就做一个简短的插话。所以我的“本期书目”是《游戏设计中的乐趣理论》，这书挺酷的。这本书是我朋友借给我的。
And basically, it goes over a theory of fun. If you were making a game, then... You might ask someone, is this game fun? Is Pac-Man fun? Is GTA 5 fun? Why are these things fun? These are super hard questions, at least for me. Because it's deeply psychological and things like that. But this tries to formalize it and i felt like it did a pretty good job it's pretty interesting um you know obviously a lot of it comes down to
基本上，它探讨了乐趣的理论。如果你正在制作一款游戏，那么……你可能会问别人，这个游戏好玩吗？吃豆人好玩吗？GTA 5 好玩吗？为什么这些东西好玩？这些是非常难的问题，至少对我来说是这样。因为这涉及深刻的心理学之类的东西。但这本书试图将其形式化，我觉得它做得相当不错，非常有趣。嗯，你知道，显然很多东西归结为
like patterns and the satisfaction that you know your brain gets when it encounters different patterns when it recognizes the pattern and things like that um it also just talks about game design at a high level and it's pretty it's a pretty good read it's very short book it's almost written like a comic book so it's not it's not heavy or anything but uh yeah it's pretty cool a theory of fun i feel like it's like weaker strong it's not fun it's funner or more fun or less fun is pac-man funner than uh gta the internet tells me all people do in the new gta is find crazy ways to die yeah yeah pretty much it's all the videos i see about it one summer that oh wow look how realistic this is and like in-game photography that's one thing and
模式，以及你的大脑在遇到不同模式、识别出模式时所获得的满足感。嗯，它也从高层面讨论了游戏设计，这是一本相当不错的读物。它非常短，写得几乎像漫画书一样，所以一点也不沉重。但嗯，是的，它很酷。《乐趣理论》，我觉得它到底是更强还是不强，它不是好玩，而是更好玩、最有趣或没那么有趣。吃豆人比 GTA 更好玩吗？互联网告诉我，人们在新的 GTA 里所做的全部事情就是寻找各种疯狂的死法。是的，基本上我看到的关于它的视频都是这样。有一个夏天，哦哇，看这多逼真，还有游戏内摄影，这是一回事，而且
the other thing is like look at this crazy way this guy died yeah gta i feel like did a huge disservice i don't know if this is true for the public at large or just me but you could pre order gta 5 a long time ago like i think like six months ago you could pre-order it and they would give you like three million in fake like gta 5 money because i guess the way it works is like even when you're playing single player, you need an internet connection. And so it keeps you from cheating, even in single player,
另一件事是，看这个家伙死得有多疯狂。是的，我觉得 GTA 做了件非常糟糕的事。我不知道这对大众来说是否属实，还是只有我这么觉得，但你可以很久之前就预购 GTA 5，我想大概是六个月前，你可以预购它，他们会给你大约 300 万的虚拟 GTA 5 货币。因为我想它的运作方式是，即使你在玩单人模式，也需要互联网连接。所以它能防止你作弊，即使是在单人模式下，
and you have to use in-game currency to buy things. Now, you can't actually spend money. It's not like a freemium or anything like that. You can't turn real money into in-game money. But the in-game money has to be kind of respected.'m assuming gta6 will have something where you could spend real money it's like going that path but the uh but so yeah so they gave you like three million i think in fake money then like about two months before it came out i saw some article about it and i was
而且你必须使用游戏内货币来购买东西。现在，你实际上不能花钱。它不像那种免费增值游戏。你不能把真钱变成游戏内货币。但游戏内货币必须得到某种程度的尊重。我假设 GTA 6 会有你可以花真钱的地方，它正朝着那个方向发展。但所以，是的，他们给了你大约 300 万的虚拟货币。然后在大约它发布前两个月，我看到了一篇关于它的文章，我
like oh that's cool so i went to see if you maybe I'd pick it up. And they had like said that you get one and a half million in fake money because basically like you're no longer an early adopter. So they only gave you that in fake money. And I kind of felt screwed like, hey, just because I didn't preorder it earlier, you know, like screw me out of 1.5 million of fake money. So I didn't buy it. And then it came out. Now you got zero. And then, yeah. And then it came out and a bunch of people like oh this game's great so i was like okay maybe i'll buy it but now there's nothing like you start with zero so now i'm like forget it i'm gonna
当时想，哦，那很酷，所以我去看看我是否要买它。他们说你只能得到 150 万的虚拟货币，因为基本上你不再是早期采用者了。所以他们只给了你那么多虚拟货币。我感觉被坑了，嘿，就因为我没有早点预购，你就坑了我 150 万的虚拟货币。所以我没买。然后它发布了。现在你得到的是零。然后，是的。然后它发布了，很多人说，哦，这游戏太棒了，所以我当时想，好吧，也许我会买它，但现在什么都没有了，你从零开始，所以我现在想，算了吧，我
wait until they've got you because now you're gonna buy you're gonna pre-order gta6 the first day it's available for pre-order oh that's their long-term strategy yes Maybe, but for GTA 5 it did not work because now I just feel like, why would I play when I'm going to be $3 million behind? I'm going to actually wait until it goes on sale instead of spending the $60. I feel like that's how I'll lose $3 million in virtual. Yeah, I'll lose $3 million in virtual currency,
等到他们抓住你的时候，因为现在你会去预购 GTA 6，在它开放预购的第一天。哦，那是他们的长期策略。是的，也许吧，但对于 GTA 5 来说这没用，因为现在我只是觉得，既然我已经落后了 300 万，我为什么还要玩呢？我实际上会等到它打折，而不是花 60 美元。我觉得这就是我损失 300 万虚拟货币的方式。是的，我会损失 300 万虚拟货币，
but I'll gain $20 in real currency. But you'll still have spent the money, so you'll still have lost. Yeah, margin is huge so yes and we this would lead perfectly into talking about the uh new kerfuffle about steam charging for mods but uh we'll save that that's right i saw that my book of the show is the programming title Monster Hunter International. This is not a book about programming. I lied. It is yet another science fiction fantasy novel. Ah, okay.
但我会省下 20 美元的真钱。但你还是花了钱，所以你还是亏了。是的，利润空间很大，所以是的。这正好引出了关于 Steam 对模组收费的新争议，但我们会留到以后再说。没错，我看到了。我的本期书目是编程书《怪物猎人国际版》。这不是一本关于编程的书。我撒谎了。它是又一部科幻奇幻小说。啊，好吧。
This one happens to be, I guess it's considered horror fantasy. Everything that's got monsters is considered horror, but this is not very dark. It's a very light book, and I was reading it, and I was just like, this is not this is not very dark um it's a very light book and i was reading it and it was just like this is a really fun book um i read the martian and i thought the martian was really fun um yeah very light-hearted book i thought like it was serious but you know like also i laughed out loud a lot um this book wasn't quite as funny um but it was really good you know just a good fast-paced goofy story almost like you'd see in a movie um and i read a lot of like deep thought provoking uh science fiction fantasies
这一部恰好是，我想它被认为是恐怖奇幻。所有有怪物的东西都被认为是恐怖，但这并不太黑暗。这是一本非常轻松的书，我在读的时候，就觉得，这并不太黑暗。嗯，这是一本非常轻松的书，我在读的时候，就觉得，这是一本非常有趣的书。嗯，我读了《火星救援》，我觉得《火星救援》非常有趣。嗯，是的，非常轻松的书。我以为它很严肃，但你知道，我也大声笑了出来。这本书没那么好笑，但它真的很棒，你知道，就是一个节奏快、傻乎乎的好故事，几乎就像你在电影里看到的那样。而且我读了很多深刻的、发人深省的科幻奇幻作品。
this wasn't like that per se um but it was a lot of fun to read and then later i read an article about this guy and i guess that's what he says he's trying to do is just write light-hearted stuff like why do we all have to be artistic and literary why can't we just write good fun to read stories um cool so that sounds great what's the theme it looks like it's like a vampire yeah it's basically about like a guy who's just almost kind of like a superhero not he doesn't have like super powers but he just like destroys monsters so like there's monsters in the world you know the government's trying to keep it secret and this guy like hunts them and there's other people that hunt them too and he you know joined forces and something really bad is happening and they're going to work to try to stop it so literally like every tv show you've ever seen um but i i listened to it on
这本身并不像那样，但读起来很有趣。后来我读了一篇关于这个家伙的文章，我想这就是他所说的他试图做的事情，只是写一些轻松的东西。为什么我们都必须是艺术性和文学性的？为什么我们不能只写一些好读、有趣的故事呢？酷，听起来很棒，主题是什么？看起来像是个吸血鬼。是的，基本上是关于一个家伙，他几乎就像个超级英雄，不是说他有超能力，但他只是摧毁怪物。所以世界上有怪物，你知道，政府试图保密，而这个家伙猎杀它们，还有其他人也猎杀它们，他加入了他们的行列，发生了一些非常糟糕的事情，他们将努力去阻止它。所以字面上就像你看过的每一部电视剧。嗯，但我是在
audible because like we mentioned last time uh that's how I do most of my listening even though I say reading because I don't have time to read I'm way too busy or I'm lazy to read so I listen to most of my books and I use Audible and we have Audible as a sponsor now so if you're interested in getting a month of free Audible
Audible 上听的，因为就像我们上次提到的，这就是我大部分时间听书的方式，尽管我说的是“读”，因为我没时间读，我太忙了，或者我懒得读，所以我大部分书都是听的。我使用 Audible，我们现在有 Audible 作为赞助商，所以如果你有兴趣获得一个月的免费 Audible，
you can check out audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown. Programming throwdowns, all lowercase, all one word, really long name. Sorry about that. Um, audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown. You can get a month free. It's pretty awesome. I recommend it after a month you get to keep the book. Um, I have many books now, uh, lots and lots of books because I have a long commute and, uh, them there are other ways to you know your library has you know audiobooks too but um yeah you had the overdrive yeah but it doesn't have nearly as many uh and you have to kind of wait for them to be available which is kind of annoying
你可以查看 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。Programming throwdowns，全小写，一个单词，名字很长。抱歉。嗯，audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown。你可以获得一个月免费。这很棒。我推荐它，一个月后你可以保留这本书。嗯，我现在有很多书，很多很多书，因为我通勤时间很长，而且还有其他方式，你知道，你的图书馆也有有声读物，但嗯，是的，你有 Overdrive，是的，但它的数量远没有那么多，而且你必须等待它们可用，这有点烦人。
and i'm really lazy so yeah and you can support the authors that way too support us and support us and support our bandwidth issues all right is it time for your sideline note or are we moving on to tool of the show um i totally forgot my sideline time for tool of the show tool of the show i'll have to make it up to you guys oh man i totally totally failed on that oh well next time i'll have to write it down tool of the show my tool of the show. So actually, so this is interesting. So I always just used whatever default shell, you know, is provided to me.
而且我真的很懒，所以是的。你也可以通过这种方式支持作者，支持我们，支持我们的带宽问题。好了，是时候讲你的侧边笔记了，还是我们要进入本期工具环节？我完全忘了我的侧边笔记，是时候讲本期工具了。本期工具，我得补偿你们。哦天哪，我在这方面完全失败了。好吧，下次我得把它写下来。本期工具，我的本期工具。所以实际上，这很有趣。我总是使用提供给我的任何默认 shell。
Like usually like in Ubuntu, it's Bash. In Solaris, it's like CSH or what have you. But then a coworker showed me, oh, my ZSH. So it's almost like a two-parter a co-worker showed me oh my zsh which is another great tool um for mac or linux which uh basically converts your shell to zsh but then also adds a bunch of other really cool things and so i've been using oh my zsh for a couple weeks weeks now. I really love it. It's amazing. If you're running Linux or Mac, you should definitely get that. But what to do on Windows, right? So I have one computer. The computer that I use to do all my Mame Hub
比如在 Ubuntu 中，通常是 Bash。在 Solaris 中，是 CSH 之类的。但后来一位同事向我展示了 Oh My ZSH。所以这几乎分成了两部分，一位同事向我展示了 Oh My ZSH，这是另一个很棒的工具，适用于 Mac 或 Linux，它基本上将你的 shell 转换为 ZSH，但也添加了许多其他非常酷的东西。所以我已经使用 Oh My ZSH 几周了。我真的很喜欢它。它太棒了。如果你运行 Linux 或 Mac，你绝对应该得到它。但在 Windows 上该怎么办呢？所以我有一台电脑。我用来做所有 Mame Hub
development is running Windows. And that, as I said, I'm doing development. So I kind of want to have a shell that isn't terrible. And so this is amazing. It's called Baboon, and it is basically, think of it as Oh My ZSH for Windows. So it kind of rolls up Siquin and ZSH and Oh My ZSH all together into one program. It's easy to install, and then you just start it up and you have this like pretty
开发的电脑运行的是 Windows。而且，正如我所说，我正在进行开发。所以我想要一个不那么糟糕的 shell。所以这个太棒了。它叫 Baboon，它基本上，把它想象成 Windows 版的 Oh My ZSH。所以它把 Siquin、ZSH 和 Oh My ZSH 全部整合到一个程序中。它很容易安装，然后你启动它，你就会拥有像在 Mac 或 Linux 电脑上那样的漂亮
awesome, you know, shell, like you would have on a Mac or on a Linux computer on your Windows desktop. It's pretty sweet. You've had a lot of good tools. But of ones I didn't know about, this looks pretty awesome. Yeah, yeah, this is pretty killer. I mean, the whole point of it is it's for Windows. So if you're not a Windows guy, this is like completely useless. But if you're not a Windows guy, get Oh My ZSH. And Oh My ZSH, you will be amazed at your productivity. If you are a Windows guy, use Baboon and it is pretty epic. I love to try this at home. At work, I tried switching to both ZSH and Phish and we should talk about shells sometime. Anyways,
很棒的 shell，在你的 Windows 桌面上。它非常甜。你有很多好工具。但在我不知道的那些工具中，这个看起来非常棒。是的，是的，这个非常杀手级。我的意思是，它的全部意义在于它是为 Windows 设计的。所以如果你不是 Windows 用户，这完全没用。但如果你不是 Windows 用户，去用 Oh My ZSH。Oh My ZSH，你会对你的生产力感到惊讶。如果你是 Windows 用户，使用 Baboon，它非常史诗。我喜欢在家里尝试这个。在工作中，我尝试切换到 ZSH 和 Fish，我们应该找时间谈谈 shell。不管怎样，
away from the default bash, but unfortunately my team has a lot of people who wrote really gnarly, awful bash scripts to set environment variables for building our project and so they're just so
远离默认的 Bash，但不幸的是，我的团队里有很多人编写了非常糟糕、可怕的 Bash 脚本来设置构建我们项目的环境变量，所以它们太
specifically bash oriented and i my bash you can always do bash and then the command no because it sets uh sets local things like it sources the scripts and you need to be able to execute them i couldn't figure out how to make it like back properly like it's so like weird i don't so i would have to run two and i've just never gotten around to it. Or maybe I just don't know enough to run one from the other. Yeah, one of the cool things about Oh My ZSH is you have one global history for all your terminal tabs.
专门针对 Bash 了，而且我的 Bash……你总是可以执行 Bash 然后跟命令，不，因为它设置了本地的东西，比如它 source 了脚本，你需要能够执行它们。我无法弄清楚如何让它正确地……这太奇怪了，所以我不得不运行两个，我一直没抽出时间。或者也许我只是不知道如何从一个运行另一个。是的，Oh My ZSH 的酷点之一是你的所有终端标签页都有一个全局历史记录。
But it's even better than that. Like the first history is local and then after that it's global. So if like you want to like just rerun the last command on like two different shells, like it'll do that that but as soon as you go one more command it goes into the global history it's very clever um but i because of that phenomena like i'll usually have like one or two tabs that are in bash and so that's because these are things where like i don't want them to pollute my history and so you could do something like that but it's not ideal fish seems like a mostly pre-configured
但它甚至比那更好。比如第一个历史记录是本地的，然后之后它是全局的。所以如果你想在两个不同的 shell 上重新运行最后一个命令，它会做到这一点，但只要你再执行一个命令，它就会进入全局历史记录，这非常聪明。嗯，但因为这种现象，我通常会有两三个标签页在 Bash 中，这是因为这些是我不想让它们污染我的历史记录的东西，所以你可以做类似的事情，但这并不理想。Fish 看起来像是一个预先配置好的
zsh and i like there that when you start typing something it auto completes to the right of your cursor like a browser oh wait it's called fish like the animal yes okay anyways f-i-s-h yes fish shell i haven't i haven't even heard of that shell yeah so like if you start typing like ls and then the start of a name it'll auto complete to the right and you can just push right arrow to choose that and i think you can do the same thing in zsh but it takes extra configuration yeah oh my zsh by default doesn't do this like but you can hit tab you can even auto complete like git branches and stuff like that it's pretty awesome but it does not uh anyways does not do that i said
ZSH，我喜欢当你开始输入某些东西时，它会在光标右侧自动补全，就像浏览器一样。哦等等，它叫 Fish，像动物一样？是的，好吧，不管怎样，F-I-S-H，是的，Fish shell。我甚至没听说过那个 shell。是的，所以如果你开始输入 ls，然后输入名字的开头，它会在右侧自动补全，你可以直接按右箭头来选择它。我想你在 ZSH 中也可以做同样的事情，但这需要额外的配置。是的，Oh My ZSH 默认不这样做，但你可以按 Tab 键，你甚至可以自动补全 git 分支之类的东西，这非常棒。但它确实不……不管怎样，它不那样做。我说
chasing off on a tangent uh and this is all very applicable because i my tool of the show this week is crouton and crouton is a project that allows a chromebook to install a ch root linux distribution so that you can and now a newly added feature is you can run uh an xfce or an ubuntu an xfce version of ubuntu or straight what is it i guess unity ubuntu um in a window application window on your Chromebook. Oh, cool. So a Chromebook is kind of limited. I wanted to be able to, in the evenings, just on the couch, on my laptop, I normally just use my Chromebook for browsing the web and typing,
跑题了，这非常适用，因为我本周的本期工具是 Crouton，Crouton 是一个允许 Chromebook 安装 chroot Linux 发行版的项目，这样你就可以……现在一个新添加的功能是，你可以在 Chromebook 的窗口应用程序窗口中运行 XFCE 或 Ubuntu 的 XFCE 版本，或者直接运行……是什么？我想是 Unity Ubuntu。哦，酷。所以 Chromebook 有点局限。我希望能够在晚上，在沙发上，在我的笔记本电脑上，我通常只用我的 Chromebook 浏览网页和打字，
or I use my iPad most of the time. But I have my Chromebook out, and I want to be able to hone my programming skills on the couch. And so I wanted to be able to not just have to ssh into my desktop but actually like on the go or whatever be able to use linux on this chromebook because i don't want to buy another laptop just for this purpose and this is great it works awesome so i yeah i use sweet xfce and it just opens it up as like a new window it shares once you get it configured it's a little wonky but shares copy and paste between the chrome browser and the chrome os part and the window that is crouton you can paste stuff
或者我大部分时间用 iPad。但我有我的 Chromebook，我想能够在沙发上磨练我的编程技能。所以我希望不必 ssh 到我的台式机，而是实际上在旅途中或任何地方都能在这个 Chromebook 上使用 Linux，因为我不想为了这个目的再买一台笔记本电脑，这太棒了，它运行得很好。所以我使用 XFCE，它就像一个新窗口一样打开。一旦你配置好它，它有点古怪，但它可以在 Chrome 浏览器、Chrome OS 部分和 Crouton 窗口之间共享复制和粘贴。你可以粘贴东西
in and get it configured run things uh you know script download whatever share between the two um and it's really awesome the only snag of rent across is because my Chromebook I have, and I think most Chromebooks are ARM, and most people's desktops are some 32-bit or 64-bit Pentium Intel processor or whatever, x86, x64. There's some tool. Most of the tools, the common tools, like in Ubuntu repositories, are compiled for ARM, but some stuff is missing. Oh, it's wild that the chromebooks are armed that's they're probably the only laptops that are arm that i that i don't know that they are all arm
进去，配置它，运行东西，你知道，脚本下载什么的，在两者之间共享。它真的很棒。我遇到的唯一障碍是因为我的 Chromebook，我想大多数 Chromebook 是 ARM 架构的，而大多数人的台式机是 32 位或 64 位的 Pentium Intel 处理器或什么的，x86, x64。有一些工具。大多数工具，常见的工具，比如 Ubuntu 仓库里的，都是为 ARM 编译的，但有些东西缺失了。哦，Chromebook 是 ARM 架构的，这太疯狂了，它们可能是唯一我不知道它们全是 ARM 的笔记本电脑。
but i think many of them are the cheap ones are and now windows is starting to push to try to have arm support as well uh but yeah so like if you download for source sometimes it won't compile for arm if you're using weird stuff and apparently there's a way to use qmu to do on the fly uh translation but if you're doing anything more than like a simple task it's just going to take forever well i wonder if you know like because android runs arm so i wonder if you're using a chromebook to do android development if the android emulator runs way faster because you actually don't need an emulator. It's now a simulator. No idea.
但我认为它们中的许多是，便宜的是。现在 Windows 也开始尝试支持 ARM 了。但是的，所以如果你从源代码下载，如果你使用奇怪的东西，有时它无法为 ARM 编译。显然有一种方法可以使用 QEMU 进行即时翻译，但如果你做的不仅仅是简单的任务，它只会花费很长时间。好吧，我想知道，因为 Android 运行 ARM，所以我不知道如果你使用 Chromebook 进行 Android 开发，Android 模拟器是否运行得更快，因为你实际上不需要模拟器。它现在是一个仿真器。不知道。
I've not tried it. But check it out, Crouton. It made my Chromebook suddenly much more useful than it was before to me. Yeah, that's killer. Even though it's another one of those, like I was saying before the show, that sometimes Linux frustrates me
我没试过。但去看看 Crouton。它让我的 Chromebook 突然比以前对我更有用了。是的，那太杀手级了。即使它是那种……就像我在节目开始前说的，有时 Linux 会让我感到沮丧，
because it takes too long to just get something working. And you've run across a problem and you spend, you know, like a whole day trying to solve your problem. But it's because I'm trying to do something really awesome. So, crouton. Well, now you'll have to go and add ARM support to all the Ubuntu packages.
因为它花太长时间才能让某样东西工作。你遇到了一个问题，然后你花了一整天时间试图解决你的问题。但这是因为我正在尝试做一些非常棒的事情。所以，Crouton。好吧，现在你得去为所有的 Ubuntu 软件包添加 ARM 支持了。
Yes, in all my free time. Yeah, right. All right, time to discuss Fortran. Fortran. So Fortran is a very early language. You don't want to be writing Fortran now unless you are working on existing Fortran code base. Like if you want to start a new web server or something,
是的，在我所有的空闲时间里。是的，没错。好了，是时候讨论 Fortran 了。Fortran。所以 Fortran 是一门非常早期的语言。除非你正在处理现有的 Fortran 代码库，否则你现在不想写 Fortran。比如如果你想启动一个新的 Web 服务器之类的，
you probably don't want to be using Fortran for your new website. But it has a pretty cool, favorable a long history very interesting and it's still in use today a lot of people use in fact you probably run you know fortran executables or code that's part that's been coded in fortran you certainly do and you don't even know it so that was a lot of caveats yeah so fortran stands for formula translating system and so it uh it was the first sort of optimizing compilers this is back you know when people were writing assembly language and i don't know did we ever i think we explained assembly and machine language you know
你可能不想为你的新网站使用 Fortran。但它有一个相当酷、有利的悠久历史，非常有趣，而且今天仍在使用。很多人在使用，事实上你可能运行过 Fortran 可执行文件或用 Fortran 编写的代码，你肯定运行过，而且你甚至不知道。所以那有很多警告。是的，所以 Fortran 代表公式翻译系统。所以它……它是第一种优化编译器。这是在人们编写汇编语言的时候，我不知道我们是否……我想我们解释过汇编和机器语言，你知道，
like four years ago we'll recap real quick so your machine does machine language which is you know each instruction is just uh uh you know an integer for the instruction name and then some some operands that are all sort of represented in integer format assembly language is a little bit higher than than just straight machine code um yeah mnemonics that's what they call it so like you get a m-n-e mnemonic mnemonic mnemonic for each like the 16-bit instruction may be like c-a and that's m-o-v move because move makes more sense to humans than CA, representing the move instruction to move one register to another. So it would be like CA-01-02, move registers 1 to register 2, and then each of those being 16 bits, then 8 bits, 8 bits,
四年前，我们快速回顾一下。所以你的机器执行机器语言，也就是你知道，每条指令只是一个整数，代表指令名称，然后是一些以整数格式表示的操作数。汇编语言比纯机器码高一点点。是的，助记符，这就是他们所说的。所以你得到一个助记符，每个 16 位指令可能是 CA，那是 MOV，移动，因为对于人类来说，移动比 CA 更容易理解，代表移动指令，将一个寄存器移动到另一个寄存器。所以它就像 CA-01-02，将寄存器 1 移动到寄存器 2，然后每个都是 16 位，然后 8 位，8 位，
would give you a 32-bit instruction. That's not how they would be divided in real life, but that would be an example. In assembly language, you would have MO r1 r2 move register one to register two for example but it's just a straight mnemonic is every assembly instruction one machine instruction nearly the some assembly let me just like it's a two-pass compiler. And in the first pass, it looks for like labels and stuff and assigns them addresses or holders. And then so that you can do branch to a label instead of branch with a numerical offset.
会给你一个 32 位指令。在现实生活中它们不会这样划分，但这只是一个例子。在汇编语言中，你会有 MO r1 r2，将寄存器 1 移动到寄存器 2，例如。但它只是一个直接的助记符。每条汇编指令是一条机器指令吗？几乎是。有些汇编……让我……它是一个两遍编译器。在第一遍中，它寻找标签之类的东西，并为它们分配地址或占位符。然后这样你就可以分支到一个标签，而不是带数值偏移的分支。
Oh, I see. So like there are things which aren't actual instructions. Oh, I see. And then those get kind of removed. Yeah, so think like variable names almost, right? But yeah, pretty much one instruction is one instruction, except for that in things like Intel processor stuff. And instruction you write in quote-unquote assembly language
哦，我明白了。所以有些东西不是实际的指令。哦，我明白了。然后那些东西会被移除。是的，所以想想变量名，对吧？但是的，几乎一条指令就是一条指令，除了在 Intel 处理器之类的东西中。你在所谓的汇编语言中编写的指令
may be many, many, many low-level instructions getting executed but it is still one instruction as issued to the processor oh okay that makes sense yeah like certain like but there's like wrappers of processors and intel processors and amd processors now yeah yeah like some cisc machines could actually like sort a list and things like that in in one instruction. But then under the hood, of course, there's all sorts of stuff going on in hardware. Right. Cool.
可能是许多、许多、许多低级指令被执行，但它仍然是发给处理器的一条指令。哦，好吧，这说得通。是的，就像某些……但现在有处理器的包装器，Intel 处理器和 AMD 处理器。是的，是的，一些 CISC 机器实际上可以在一条指令中对列表进行排序之类的。但在底层，当然，硬件中发生着各种各样的事情。没错。酷。
Okay. So, Fortran is the first optimizing compiler. So, it actually is the first time where somebody said, let's build sort of a higher level language on top of assembly and then also let's diagnose what the person's intent was and see if we can make like even better assembly than what they intended while preserving uh you know they're the same logic while preserving the same computation um which makes sense because we think today the opposite like oh if i want to make it better i'll write it in assembly like that's the ultimate optimization but there are some optimizations they're just way too tedious you wouldn't ever code by hand like loop unrolling like just writing the same c code a hundred times to unroll a loop
好的。所以，Fortran 是第一个优化编译器。所以它实际上是第一次有人说，让我们在汇编之上构建一种更高级的语言，然后让我们诊断这个人的意图是什么，看看我们是否能做出比他们预期的更好的汇编，同时保留……你知道，相同的逻辑，同时保留相同的计算。这说得通，因为我们今天想的是相反的，比如，哦，如果我想让它更好，我会用汇编编写，那是终极优化。但有些优化太繁琐了，你永远不会手工编写，比如循环展开，只是把相同的 C 代码写一百遍来展开一个循环，
you just won't you wouldn't do that like that's just annoying people would tell you just go write a loop but it may make sense if the compiler understands more about the state of the system to unroll the loop for you but you would never hopefully use like a pound define or something sure a macro or something right but like an assembly language you know there's not necessarily the same conveniences so you may not write in that style and it's a little harder to view the structure of the program with an assembly language interpreter than writing in a higher level language where it can understand the flow a little easier. Gotcha. That makes sense.
你只是不会，你不会那样做，那太烦人了。人们会告诉你直接写一个循环。但如果编译器对系统状态有更多了解，为你展开循环可能是有意义的，但你永远不会希望使用像 #define 之类的东西，当然是宏之类的，对吧？但像汇编语言，你知道，不一定有同样的便利，所以你可能不会用那种风格编写，而且用汇编语言解释器查看程序的结构比用高级语言编写要难一点，因为高级语言可以更容易地理解流程。明白了。这说得通。
Yeah, I saw something about how like Java, like in certain very specific cases, Java is way, way faster than C because of the way the just-in-time compiler works. It can like unroll loops. Right. It understands at this moment moment your system, all the run time variables are now known and if you do it over and over again it's the exact optimal version right so history of Fortran
是的，我看到一些关于 Java 的东西，比如在某些非常具体的情况下，Java 比 C 快得多，因为即时编译器的工作方式。它可以像展开循环一样。没错。它在这一刻理解你的系统，所有的运行时变量现在都是已知的，如果你一遍又一遍地做，它就是完全最优的版本。所以 Fortran 的历史。
Fortran was first designed 1953 by John W. Bacchus he claimed it had 20 times fewer instructions than assembly to do the same task, same coding task. Sounds like a big promise. Yeah, I know. It sounds like the GPU promises that we're seeing now. So his point, he wrote programs for IBM for computing missile trajectories. And he was saying he was lazy and didn't want to write so much
Fortran 最初由 John W. Bacchus 于 1953 年设计。他声称它比汇编完成同样的任务、同样的编码任务所需的指令少 20 倍。听起来是个大承诺。是的，我知道。听起来像我们现在看到的 GPU 承诺。所以他的观点是，他为 IBM 编写计算导弹轨迹的程序。他说他很懒，不想写那么多
assembly that's what he's quoted as saying so he thought it would be more efficient for him to invent Fortran than to have to do all of those all that assembly programming and maybe it was but either way he he definitely could be considered a philanthropist of sorts because he wrote Fortran and everyone else could benefit, which is pretty cool. Um, so Fortran sort of harkens to like a very early day of computing, definitely before our time.
汇编，这就是他所说的。所以他认为发明 Fortran 比不得不做所有那些汇编编程更有效率。也许是这样，但无论如何，他绝对可以被认为是一种慈善家，因为他编写了 Fortran，其他人都可以受益，这很酷。嗯，所以 Fortran 有点让人想起计算的早期，绝对是在我们之前。
But, uh, you know, our parents are, if your parents are kind of techie, uh, then, uh,
但是，嗯，你知道，我们的父母是……如果你的父母有点懂技术，嗯，那么，
if you're old as we are and you have parents who are techie, or maybe your grandparents were techie, they can tell you about these crazy stories of using punch cards. And actually with Fortran, back in the day, people would use a special machine, kind of like a typewriter, but when you typed C, it would actually punch a hole, or maybe two holes into a card and then move the card a little bit, kind of like a typewriter but with holes instead of – imagine like a Braille typewriter or something like that.
如果你像我们一样老，并且你有懂技术的父母，或者也许你的祖父母懂技术，他们可以告诉你这些关于使用打孔卡的疯狂故事。实际上对于 Fortran，在过去，人们会使用一种特殊的机器，有点像打字机，但当你输入 C 时，它实际上会在卡片上打一个孔，或者可能是两个孔，然后把卡片稍微移动一下，有点像打字机，但有孔而不是……想象一下像盲文打字机之类的东西。
And so you would type out all of your instructions. If you mistyped something, you would just have to throw that card away and start over. And when you were all done done you would take your stack of cards and hopefully don't drop them and get them scrambled on the floor yeah if you drop them forget it right like i think they're numbered it's kind of like you know how like your your checkbook has numbers so so if you drop it you can like you know do a human quicksort but nobody wants to do that so uh um you would take them over to like the um i think it's like there's a special name for it like a secretary or something but there's like a
所以你会打出你所有的指令。如果你打错了什么，你只需要把那张卡片扔掉重新开始。当你全部完成时，你会拿着你的卡片堆，希望不要把它们掉在地上弄乱。是的，如果你掉落它们，算了吧，对吧？我想它们是有编号的，这有点像你知道你的支票簿有编号一样。所以如果你掉落它，你可以像……你知道，做一个人类快速排序，但没人想那样做。所以嗯，你会把它们带到……我想这有一个特殊的名称，像秘书之类的，但有一个
reader cool name for it no like well you take them to a person who would feed it into the machine and then the computer basically is that what the i was thinking that but i would anyway there's a person who would their whole job was to take these punch cards like stacks of them feed them into the machine machine would take maybe like half an hour um and then spit out some some results on i guess like a like a kind of like a cash register would on a piece of paper and they would you know attach it to the to the punch cards and give it back to you so you so imagine like you would you would submit your program depending on like how much work this this gentleman or lady had uh you'd get your program back you hours later and you'd find like oh i had a you know some runtime error or something like
读取器，酷的名字。不，像……好吧，你把它们带给一个会把它们喂进机器的人，然后计算机基本上……这就是我当时想的，但无论如何，有一个人，他们的全部工作就是拿着这些打孔卡，成堆地喂进机器。机器可能需要半小时，然后吐出一些结果，我想是在一张纸上，就像收银机那样。他们会把它们附在打孔卡上还给你。所以想象一下，你会提交你的程序，取决于这位先生或女士有多少工作，你会在几小时后拿回你的程序，你会发现，哦，我有一个运行时错误之类的
that it's just like unbelievable um that you could get anything done like that um but people did for years and years but while you're waiting you just surfed the web on your iphone so i wonder if someone wrote like a fortran yeah there are punch card emulators i found i was i yes yeah are there ones for the web? Let me check out. There were. There were ones on the web. I just was looking.
那真是令人难以置信，你能那样完成任何事情。但人们做了很多年。但在等待的时候，你只是在 iPhone 上浏览网页。所以我不知道是否有人写过像 Fortran……是的，有打孔卡模拟器，我找到了，我……是的，有网页版的吗？让我看看。有。网页上有。我刚才在看。
They look almost like they're just for aesthetic purposes. I couldn't find anywhere you actually punch your punch cards and feed them in or anything. Oh, okay. But there is a punch card computer I found the other day, like a printoutable. You make punch cards, and you slide it through, and it's an actual, like, You physically do the computations by...
它们看起来几乎只是为了美观。我找不到任何你可以实际打孔并喂进去的地方。哦，好吧。但我前几天发现了一个打孔卡计算机，像可打印的。你制作打孔卡，然后把它滑进去，它是一个实际的，像，你物理上通过……进行计算。
Anyways, it was very intriguing. I want to teach this to my kids one day because I'm a nerdy. Yeah, this is amazing. I found a website where you can type anything you want, and it will put it on a punch card. But just imagine... The worst is you punch all this stuff on the punch card,
不管怎样，这非常引人入胜。我想有一天教我的孩子这个，因为我是个书呆子。是的，这太棒了。我找到了一个网站，你可以输入任何你想要的东西，它会把它放在打孔卡上。但试想一下……最糟糕的是你把所有这些东西打在打孔卡上，
and then your program has a bug in it, right it right like it doesn't compile and then it's like oh yeah i mean like there's physical ramifications beyond just crackles of energy for your code not compiling like you you have to start retyping things like think of all those dead trees you wasted that's not green like if if you have an error do you have to type every card from that point on to the end or can you like splice in i'm sure you can splice in why i mean i don't think it enforces the numbering yeah i guess that's true it's like how do you that's how you make me too man yeah oh man uh yeah that's completely mind-blowing as a new uh new meaning to technical debt yeah that's the literal weight of the cards for your system
然后你的程序里有一个 bug，对吧？它不编译，然后就像，哦，是的。我的意思是，除了代码不编译带来的能量消耗之外，还有物理后果。你必须开始重新输入东西。想想你浪费的所有死树，那不环保。如果有一个错误，你必须从那一点到最后输入每一张卡片吗？还是你可以拼接？我肯定你可以拼接。为什么？我的意思是，我不认为它强制执行编号。是的，我想那是真的。就像你怎么做……这就是你让我……天哪，是的，那完全令人震惊，作为一种新的技术债务含义。是的，那是你系统卡片的字面重量。
so uh obviously you know nobody had a computer in 1950 just hanging out they were there was a handful of well there's more than a handful of computers but there was your one computer for maybe you know 10 or 20 people and so at least and so um these are called mainframes and uh and so uh you know that one person who's just feeding all the punch cards through is interacting with the computer everyone else is just you know interacting with the punch cards um fortran still gets used today but not punch cards as far as i know hopefully but yeah fortran still lives on in many places where you do numerical processing so you may have come across it before i heard about it it still backs some of the most well-known uh linear algebra systems like la pack uh lots of matlab i believe modules are still in fortran
所以，显然，你知道，1950 年没人有电脑。只有少数……有不止少数的电脑，但你可能只有一台电脑供 10 或 20 个人使用，至少是这样。所以，嗯，这些被称为大型机。所以，嗯，你知道，那个喂打孔卡的人正在与计算机交互，其他人只是在与打孔卡交互。Fortran 今天仍然在使用，但据我所知不是打孔卡，希望如此。但是的，Fortran 在许多进行数值处理的地方仍然存在。所以你可能以前听说过它。它仍然支持一些最著名的线性代数系统，比如 LAPACK。我相信很多 Matlab 模块仍然是用 Fortran 编写的，
and optimized that way um and it's just really useful for people doing scientific computing where this is like where it kind of got its start uh and so like in high performance computing and stuff fortran is used often and uh it just carries over that really high performance people wanted to use it and so the high performance high performance modules still often have Fortran in them that's right like if you do anything on your computer with images like any kind of image
并以这种方式优化。而且对于进行科学计算的人来说，它非常有用，这是它起步的地方。所以像在高性能计算之类的领域，Fortran 经常被使用。它延续了那种真正的高性能，人们想使用它，所以高性能模块通常仍然包含 Fortran。没错，就像如果你在电脑上做任何关于图像的事情，任何种类的图像
manipulation at all even if you just like turn a PNG into a JPEG you're using Fortran code like it's absolutely everywhere. It's on every machine. So it's completely ubiquitous. But, you know, granted, most people probably don't even know
操作，即使你只是把 PNG 转成 JPEG，你也在使用 Fortran 代码。它绝对无处不在。它在每台机器上。所以它完全无处不在。但是，你知道，当然，大多数人可能甚至不知道
what that code is doing. I mean, they know the intent of the code, but they couldn't, you know, fix bugs. Well, it's like anything. The more optimized it becomes, the harder to read it typically becomes yeah that's true too yeah the more obtuse the optimizations chosen are yeah right so um so there's a few modern compilers for fortran uh fortran just like c++ you know it had c++ has has the original version which was uh written in, the compiler was written in C. Actually, sorry, the compiler, it was written in C, and it also generated C code.
那段代码在做什么。我的意思是，他们知道代码的意图，但他们无法修复 bug。好吧，这就像任何事情一样。它变得越优化，通常就越难阅读。是的，那也是真的。选择的优化越晦涩。是的，没错。所以，嗯，有一些现代的 Fortran 编译器。Fortran 就像 C++，你知道，它有最初的版本，它是用 C 编写的。实际上，抱歉，编译器是用 C 编写的，它也生成 C 代码。
So it didn't go straight from C++ to the machine. There's multiple iterations on that. There were kind of tweaks to the language over the years. And then now we have the C++11, right? It's the same with Fortran. There was an original version of Fortran. There's a very popular one called Fortran. Wait, I think we have C++11, right? It's the same with Fortran. There was an original version of Fortran. There's a very popular one called Fortran. I think we have C++14 now.
所以它没有直接从 C++ 到机器。这有多次迭代。多年来对语言进行了一些调整。然后现在我们有了 C++11，对吧？Fortran 也是一样。有一个最初的 Fortran 版本。有一个非常流行的叫 Fortran……等等，我想我们有 C++11，对吧？Fortran 也是一样。有一个最初的 Fortran 版本。有一个非常流行的叫 Fortran。我想我们现在有 C++14 了。
What? Yeah, C++14 is a thing. And I think they already have C++17 is in the works now. You're behind, man. What? I'm so far behind. I'll have to look into that and find out what they added in 14. Wow. That's like a return
什么？是的，C++14 是个东西。而且我想他们已经在开发 C++17 了。你落后了，伙计。什么？我落后太多了。我得研究一下，看看他们在 14 中添加了什么。哇。那就像一个返回
type deduction, relaxed const expressions, variable templates, aggregate member initialization, digit separators, generic lambdas. These are all C++14 features. Oh, generic lambdas, really? Like function pointer kind of thing? Well, in C++11
类型推导、宽松的 const 表达式、变量模板、聚合成员初始化、数字分隔符、泛型 lambda。这些都是 C++14 的特性。哦，泛型 lambda，真的吗？像函数指针之类的东西？好吧，在 C++11 中，
the lambda function parameters had to be declared with concrete types but in 14 that requirement got relaxed oh okay this is patrick reading excerpts from wikipedia um so yeah so compile so now you know i'm assuming g95 is implementing the Fortran 95, which is that version of Fortran. There's also GNU or GNU G Fortran. That's the one I've used to build SciPy. Yeah, it's part of the GCC collection. That's right. So if you have GCC, which most machines do, you also have G Fortran.
lambda 函数参数必须用具体类型声明，但在 14 中，该要求放宽了。哦，好吧，这是 Patrick 在读维基百科的摘录。所以，是的，所以编译器……现在你知道了，我假设 g95 正在实现 Fortran 95，那是 Fortran 的那个版本。还有 GNU 或 GNU G Fortran。那是我用来构建 SciPy 的那个。是的，它是 GCC 集合的一部分。没错。所以如果你有 GCC，大多数机器都有，你也有 G Fortran。
And so if you have to build SciPy from source or if you want to um you'll have to you'll have to have that installed and you'll see i did that once and yeah and then i was like wow it's taking a long time yeah it takes forever so the interesting thing it'll actually um like recompile the same program many times to find the best way to compile it. It's kind of like mind-blowing. So yeah, so those are the compilers in a nutshell. So, what are some pros of Fortran? Punch cards! Punch cards!
所以如果你必须从源代码构建SciPy，或者如果你想这样做，你必须安装它。你会看到我曾经做过一次，是的，然后我就想，哇，这花的时间太长了。是的，这需要永远。有趣的是，它实际上会多次重新编译同一个程序，以找到最佳的编译方式。这简直令人难以置信。所以，这就是简而言之的编译器。那么，Fortran有哪些优点呢？打孔卡！打孔卡！
I mean, come on! Like, what language is freaking punch cards? Only people who have never had to program in punch cards before would be so excited as punch cards as jason and i yeah i just like uh man i mean talk i wonder if uh we could we could get our hands on some punch cards someone told me that some of the computer museums have them but they think that they may not let you run your own programs anymore oh oh i see they'll have the like place where you just gotta yeah i really want to one day just to say i could but i don't know if you could like that seems like
我是说，拜托！什么语言会用打孔卡？只有那些以前从未用过打孔卡编程的人才会像杰森和我一样对打孔卡感到如此兴奋。我只是想，天哪，我在想我们是否能弄到一些打孔卡。有人告诉我，一些计算机博物馆有这些东西，但他们认为他们可能不再让你运行自己的程序了。哦，我明白了，他们会有那种让你操作的地方。是的，我真的有一天想试一下，只是为了说我能做到，但我不知道你是否能做到，这看起来像是
something that has like moving parts that you couldn't just buy an old one on ebay and expect it to work so like if you're like we'd have to find an emulator yeah yeah yeah that's right but if you have an emulator it kind of defeats the point like it'd be pretty sweet if we could you should make one with an arduino oh punch card if we could take like a transpiler like go like use if there's a g4 tran that goes to llvm then you could take like a very complicated like you could take some neural network compile it to llM, then transpile it to Fortran, and then run it on one of those old machines. I want to compile my JavaScript Node.js program to assembly on punch cards. The server is like, please wait while we read these punch cards. Please wait while we read these 17 million punch cards oh no i'm gonna make
那种有活动部件的东西，你不能只是在eBay上买个旧的就指望它能用。所以，如果我们想的话，我们得找个模拟器。是的，没错，但如果你有一个模拟器，那就有点违背初衷了。如果我们能用Arduino做一个，那就太棒了。哦，打孔卡，如果我们能用一个转译器，比如用一个能转成LLVM的GFortran，那么你就可以拿一个非常复杂的神经网络，把它编译成LLVM，然后转译成Fortran，然后在那些旧机器上运行。我想把我的JavaScript Node.js程序编译成打孔卡上的汇编语言。服务器就像是，请稍候，我们正在读取这些打孔卡。请稍候，我们正在读取这1700万张打孔卡。哦不，我要在工作中做这个。
that at work i'm gonna measure my productivity and number of punch cards it would have taken to do my work so like instead of like system lines of code or whatever like i generated 100 slot it's like i generated 10 billion punch cards today. That'd be amazing. Yeah, using the transpiler and all that, you could do it. It's like you're 3 million GTA dollars. Yeah, that's right. That's right. I generated 3 million punch cards worth of codes.
我要衡量我的生产力，看看完成我的工作需要多少张打孔卡。所以，与其说是系统代码行数之类的，不如说是我今天生成了100亿张打孔卡。那太棒了。是的，使用转译器和所有这些，你可以做到。就像你有300万GTA美元一样。是的，没错。没错。我生成了价值300万张打孔卡的代码。
That's the new byline of our show. Increasing your punch card output by immeasurable percentages. I totally think the next logo or a logo of programming throwdown has to be this punch card that i'm looking at right now that has that has yeah that looks awesome that's like one of those like binary clocks where you get it like for the novelty and then you spend a year trying to read it. Okay. And? All right.
这是我们节目的新口号。以无法估量的百分比提高你的打孔卡产量。我完全认为Programming Throwdown的下一个标志，或者标志，必须是我现在看到的这张打孔卡。那看起来太棒了，就像那种二进制时钟，你为了新鲜感而买它，然后花了一年时间试图读懂它。好的。还有呢？好吧。
So another pro about Fortran is pretty cool. It's pretty unique. So Fortran actually started some of the trends of doing kind of crazy things to optimize the code. And Fortran kind of started that whole movement. Fortran had a directive called frequency. So you've probably used this, Patrick. Have you used the register directive in C?
所以Fortran的另一个优点是它非常酷。它非常独特。Fortran实际上开启了一些为了优化代码而做疯狂事情的趋势。Fortran开启了整个运动。Fortran有一个名为frequency的指令。帕特里克，你可能用过这个。你在C语言中使用过register指令吗？
All the time. Seriously? Yeah, seriously. I would have used that a lot. It just actually registers. There's a better way to do it. But yes, I know what you're talking about. Register, because that's optional.
一直都在用。真的吗？是的，真的。我经常用它。它实际上只是寄存器。有更好的方法来做这件事。但是的，我知道你在说什么。Register，因为那是可选的。
But there's a way to force it to be aliased to an actual register. Yeah, I was going to say register doesn an actual register anything ah well it's supposed to be a hint but i don't know that it actually works um but there's a way to actually force the compiler to use to save a register and then use that register for the variable you're using uh okay it's like some kind of maybe it's gcc specific i don't know but there's like a more forceful way to do the same thing yeah that makes sense like something kind of like underscore underscore blah blah blah or something
但有一种方法可以强制它别名为实际的寄存器。是的，我正想说，register并不真正寄存任何东西。啊，好吧，它应该是一个提示，但我不知道它是否真的有效。但有一种方法可以强制编译器使用并保存一个寄存器，然后将该寄存器用于你正在使用的变量。好吧，这就像是某种可能是GCC特有的东西，我不知道，但有一种更强有力的方法来做同样的事情。是的，这很有道理，就像某种类似下划线下划线之类的东西。
it's probably that and it's GCC maybe I don't remember the syntax so the register thing in C is not used anymore like modern compilers I don't think respected anymore because they've found like statistically they took like So the register thing in C is not used anymore. Like modern compilers, I don't think respect it anymore because they've found like statistically,
那可能是那个，而且可能是GCC，我不记得语法了。所以C语言中的register东西不再使用了，因为现代编译器我认为不再尊重它了，因为他们发现，从统计学上讲，他们采取了……所以C语言中的register东西不再使用了。就像现代编译器，我认为不再尊重它了，因为他们发现，从统计学上讲，
they took like the top 100 programs that had register and they found that if you took away register, it actually performed better because the compiler is just so much smarter than we are. So register became a no-op like a few years back. And frequency is also a no-op in Fortran, but it used to actually tell Fortran to do some Monte Carlo simulation, which we talked about in our earlier episodes.
他们选取了前100个使用register的程序，发现如果你去掉register，它的性能实际上更好，因为编译器比我们聪明得多。所以register在几年前变成了一个空操作。frequency在Fortran中也是一个空操作，但它过去确实告诉Fortran进行一些蒙特卡洛模拟，我们在之前的剧集中讨论过。
We talked about rejection sampling and things like that. But yeah, the Fortran compiler would do a Monte Carlo simulation to figure out how to lay the blocks of codes and blocks of code in a way that is most efficient um and and it makes sense because this guy was at ibm uh working on missile uh you know guidance simulation which is full of monte carlo sampling so he's probably an expert on that and so he put it into his compiler which is pretty sweet i should clarify too my use of register was because i was about to write inline assembly um for accessing special registers on the processor so it wasn't for speed oh interesting okay i remember uh off topic doing
我们讨论过拒绝采样之类的事情。但确实，Fortran编译器会进行蒙特卡洛模拟，以找出如何以最有效的方式布置代码块。这很有道理，因为这个人曾在IBM工作，从事导弹制导模拟，这充满了蒙特卡洛采样，所以他可能是这方面的专家，所以他把它放进了他的编译器里，这很棒。我也应该澄清一下，我使用register是因为我当时要编写内联汇编，用于访问处理器上的特殊寄存器，所以它不是为了速度。哦，有趣，好的。我记得在FPGA工作中，你会写入某个内存块。你只是写x=3，它就一直挂在那里，你永远不会使用x。我记得看着那段代码，心想我不是一个更理论化的计算机科学人员，所以我只是看到这个x=3挂在那里，我就想这没有任何意义。你为什么要这样做？有人告诉我，变量x指向某个特殊的内存，还有另一个处理器，比如FPGA，正在监听那个内存，所以当你执行x=3时，它会立即进入这个处理器。这就像一旦
fpga work where uh you know like you'd write to a certain block of memory. You would just do x equals 3 and it'd just be hanging out there and you'd never use x. I remember looking at that code and thinking I'm not a more theoretical comp sci guy so I just saw this x equals 3 hanging out and I was like this doesn't make any sense. Why do you do this? Someone told me that variable x is pointing to some special memory and there's this other processor like fpj that's listening to that memory and so when you do x equals three like it immediately goes into this other processor and uh um this is just like once
你进入底层的东西，就会有一堆这种……是的，所以我做过类似的事情，你必须将其标记为volatile，进行内存映射。如果你愿意，可以使用链接器，或者还有其他方法可以基本上将其放置在特定地址，然后当你访问这些地址时，位就会出现在特殊的总线上，FPGA会监听该总线并做出适当的响应，要么存储数据，要么在你尝试读取时将其写回给你。这是一种沟通方式，与I2C或SPI之类的不同，因为数据速率可以高得多，因为它就像是内存映射的RAM，但它实际上是一个处理器。是的，我的意思是
you get into low level stuff there's a bunch of these kind of yeah so i've done it like that you have to mark it volatile memory map it you can use a linker if you want or there's other ways to basically place at a specific address and then when you access those addresses the bits come out on a special bus and the fpga listens to that bus and responds appropriately either storing the data or writing it back to you when you try to read it and it's a kind of a way to communicate um that's different than like i squared c or spi or something because the data rates can be much higher because it's meant for as if it was just memory mapped ram but it's really a processor yeah i mean i'm
假设数据速率可以高达跟踪速度，或者高达其他处理器运行的速度之类的。它可以非常快，它是可配置的。是的，这取决于处理器。你如何确保对方已经读取了它？我的意思是，他们只需要提供一个保证，即他们满足时序规范。哦，我明白了，所以它被时钟输出，他们必须保证，比如FPGA设计，它不像处理器那样工作，对吧？同时进行，所以它流入的逻辑能够消耗你传输的字节，在它们消失之前。明白了，哦，我明白你的意思了，是的，这很有道理。
assuming it the the data rate could be as high as like the trace right or as high as the other processors running or something like that it can be really fast it's configurable yeah it depends on the processor how do you ensure that the other person has read it i mean they just have to provide a guarantee that they meet the timing spec oh i see so it gets clocked out and they have to guarantee like an fpga design that it doesn't work like a processor right simultaneous so like the logic it flows into is capable of uh consuming the byte or bytes you transfer before they go away got it oh i see what you're saying yeah yeah that makes sense
就像是传播速度，而不是处理器速度。所以你基本上需要读取该信息，并在再次写入之前将其传递到流水线的下一阶段。是的，类似那样。是的，酷。那么Fortran的缺点是什么？Fortran。是的，基本上，不要使用Fortran。我的意思是，你知道，MATLAB、R、SciPy要好得多。你知道，工具要好得多。对读取图像等所有这些东西的支持，在这些其他语言中要优越得多。所以，我的意思是，Fortran很酷。
like it's propagation speed not uh like processor speed yeah so you basically it needs to read that information um and pass it on to the next stage in the pipeline before you get write it again yep something like that yep um cool so what are the cons of fortran um Fortran. Yeah, basically, don't use Fortran. I mean, like, you know, MATLAB, R, SciPy are just way better. You know, the tooling is way better. The support for, you know, reading images, all these things, just so much superior in these other languages. So, I mean, Fortran is cool.
正如我所说，你知道，我们所有人都在运行Fortran代码，大多数人对此一无所知。所以出于这个原因，它非常酷。你甚至可能需要调试一些Fortran代码，特别是如果你正在做一些图像处理之类的东西。但实际上在这一点上，它只是一个很酷的历史课。
As I said, you know, all of us are running Fortran code, unbeknownst to most of us. And so for that reason, it's very cool. And you might even have to debug some Fortran code, especially if you're doing some image processing or something like that. But really at this point, it's just kind of like a cool history lesson.
你不应该尝试构建你的下一个网站，不幸的是，杰森的强烈背书。是的，是的，杰森，杰森不支持这个信息，我不赞同这个信息。没错，是的，我不赞同这个信息。但它很酷，去看看吧。这是一个值得了解的有趣东西。正如我所说，你可以通过告诉你的朋友他们的电脑正在运行Fortran代码而他们甚至不知道来震惊他们。因为你所有的朋友都想听到这个。是的，没错。你会成为那个人。你已经是那个人了。
You should not try and build your next website unfortunately what the ringing endorsement of jason yeah yeah jason jason does not uh does not support this message i do not approve this message that's right yeah i do not approve this message um but it's cool, check it out. It's an interesting one to know. As I said, you could shock your friends by telling them that their computer is running Fortran code and they don't even know it. Because all your friends want to hear that. Yeah, that's right. You'll become that guy. You are already that guy.
是的，我们曾经是那个人。我们一直是那个人。我就是那个人。是的，我们是那个人，我们曾经是那个人，我们一直是那个人，我就是那个人。好吧，下次见。我想这就是我所要说的。好吧，伙计们，祝你们愉快。开场音乐是Binar Pilot的Axo。Programming Throwdown
Yeah, we were that guy. We've been that guy. I am that guy yeah we're that we were that guy we've been that guy I am that guy alright till next time I think that's I think that's it for me alright guys have a good one the intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot programming throwdown
是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。